Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, hast du dir am Wochenende auch dein Demo-Geld abgeholt?
Ich bin zu spät gekommen. Die war, die Antifa GmbH, schon insolvent.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 482 vom 22.
Januar 2024, kurz nachdem Deutschland erwacht ist. Hat man so den Eindruck.
Oder? Gemerkt hat, wie man sich da eingetreten hat, ne?
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein bewegtes Wochenende liegt hinter uns.
Aber du hast kein Demo-Gelb bekommen?
Nee, das war...
Aber du warst schon da? Also hast du jetzt quasi Überstunden gemacht?
Überfüllt und trotzdem da Versammlungsabbruch-Antifa.
Berlin hat es nicht geschafft. Ich habe es befürchtet.
Versammlungsabbruch. Köln, Hamburg, München, die haben alle Versammlungsabbruch
wegen Überfüllung geschafft.
Berlin, knapp nicht. Wie stehen wir jetzt da?
Ja, naja, ich meine, ein Lob an die Polizei, die hat dann halt einfach mal 17.
Juni gesperrt. Auf einmal war dann von Brandenburger Tor bis Siegessäule,
das war so der Tweet, hab ich gesehen, ich war nicht da, ich war auf der anderen
Seite, aber die haben dann einfach mal gesagt, leider wenn das hier ein Love
Parade ist, dann nochmal Siegessäule auch noch mit dazu.
Sie haben allerdings dann auch den kompletten Zufall mit dem ÖPNV gesperrt.
Also die S-Bahn haben nicht mehr da gehalten, die U5 hat nicht mehr da gehalten,
um halt einer Überfüllung entgegenzuwirken.
Nur einer hat das Memo nicht bekommen, als wir dann langsam gegangen sind.
Das haben wir ja auch gesagt, Leute, geht jetzt mal lieber langsam,
so vorsichtig und gemütlich.
Dann haben wir auch so in Segmente aufgeteilt, dieses Segment bleibt noch ein
bisschen hier, wir singen noch ein Lied zusammen, damit halt diese Menschenmasse
irgendwie halbwegs gesund da abwandern kann.
Damit ich da irgendwie am Paul-Löbe-Haus entlang und dann diese Brücke, die da in Richtung...
Nee, nee, nee, in die andere Richtung.
Friedrichstadtpalast. Die Brücke, die da... Und da steht dann so ein einsamer
Polizist und sagt so, hier bitte nicht lang.
Aber da laufen halt so Tausende Menschen, die von der Demo... Nee, hier nicht.
Wir sperren das jetzt hier. Ich sag, wieso sperren sie denn jetzt den...
Das ist der offizielle Demo-Trail gewesen. Die sind aber falsch rumgelaufen.
Das war alles eine totale Katastrophe. Die haben auch falsche...
Der war wirklich nicht die hellste Kerze. Also er war auch, sag ich mal,
so wenig hell, dass er auch nicht gemerkt hat, dass wir einfach weitergegangen sind.
Worüber reden wir? Wir reden über die umfangreiche Demonstrationsaktivität in
Deutschland, die an diesem Wochenende stattgefunden hat, die auch schon die
Tage davor stattgefunden hat. Warum? Warum?
Weil alle sich ausnahmsweise mal über Nazis aufregen.
Nicht wie sonst, wo man dann immer das so zur Kenntnis nimmt und dann ist wieder alles so wie vorher.
Es scheint was passiert zu sein. Und der Grund dafür ist der Artikel vom Korrektiv-Kollektiv.
Nein, ist kein Kollektiv.
Was?
Ist kein Kollektiv. Ich habe es auch letztens gesagt.
Okay, dann sagen wir von Kollektiv. Wir werden gleich klären, was es ist.
Denn darüber wollen wir uns heute unterhalten. Wir haben den Geheimplan gegen Deutschland.
Und dafür begrüßen wir den Jean heute in unserer Runde.
Jean Peters, hallo. Herzlich willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Hallo. Eine Freude, hier zu sein.
Endlich. Genau.
Und dich haben wir eingeladen, weil du so ein bisschen mitschuldig bist,
weil du auch für Korrektiv tätig bist.
Und ja, da ist auf jeden Fall fleißig gearbeitet worden, ganz offensichtlich.
Denn dieser Artikel ist ja ein bisschen eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe,
so kann man fast sagen. Also das hat mich auch ein bisschen überrascht.
Nicht, dass ich das als unangemessen empfinden würde, ich fand das als sehr angemessen,
bloß normalerweise hat man halt immer solche Veröffentlichungen und dann passiert
halt irgendwie gefühlt nichts oder die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne bricht dann spätestens
mit dem nächsten Helene Fischer Album dann auch schon wieder komplett ein.
Ja, das stimmt. Genau.
Und das war anders so. Und warum das diesmal so anders so war,
darüber wollen wir heute mal quatschen. Sehr gerne.
Dich vorstellen.
Genau, wir müssen nämlich jetzt erstmal fragen, wer bist denn du eigentlich?
Jean, kannst du das mal sagen?
Ja, also mein Name ist Jean, Jean Peters und ich arbeite seit,
weiß ich nicht, eineinhalb Jahren für Korrektiv.
Ich habe für vorher, ich habe 2019 da schon mal eine Recherche veröffentlicht
zu KlimawandelleugnerInnen und bei Korrektiv gendern wir glaube ich nicht dabei sein.
Bist du denn ein gelernter Journalist?
Ich war nicht an einer Journalistenschule. Ich habe das gelernt peu à peu.
Also ich arbeite eigentlich so zwischen Aktionskunst und Journalismus.
Das sind so zwei Gewerke, die ich gelernt habe. Ich habe das Peng-Kollektiv
gegründet vor etwa zehn Jahren.
Da haben wir viel Schabernack gemacht. Da kam ich eben in diese Medienwelt und
habe gelernt, wie die Strukturen funktionieren.
Überhaupt, da war ich sozusagen wie so ein bisschen auf der anderen Seite.
Also da hatte ich die Medien, würde
ich beschreiben, so ein bisschen aus künstlerischer Perspektive bespielt.
Wir haben Aktionen gemacht, investigative Interventionen habe ich das irgendwann
genannt, weil wir natürlich viel recherchiert haben und uns die Dinge komplexer
angeguckt haben und überlegt haben, wo kann man denn da einen Stich setzen,
was sind Bilder, die man schaffen kann, die die Probleme zusammenfassen und
vor allem und das finde ich bemerkenswert an der aktuellen Situation ist,
dass eine der Dinge, die mich immer rumgetrieben haben ist, wie kann man in
einer Welt, die einen ständig überfordert und in eine Art von Lähmung und Ohnmacht
bringt, diese Ohnmacht durchbrechen.
und das habe ich mit Peng dann geübt, geübt, geübt und dann irgendwann habe
ich bei Jan Böhmermann gearbeitet,
Das war eine super tolle Zeit, weil ich da auch nochmal eine ganz andere Form
von Impact lernen konnte, sehen konnte, wie Fernsehen funktioniert.
Und ja auch im Rechercheteam dann bei Böhmermann, ne?
Ja.
Redaktion, Redaktion.
Ich war Autor offiziell, also was sozusagen, da gibt es ja verschiedene Kategorien,
auch da war ich als Autor, aber ich habe viel recherchiert.
Ich war so ein bisschen so ein Zwitter zwischen den verschiedenen Abteilungen.
Warst du dann immer schuld, wenn sich Linus hier aufregt, bist du schuld gewesen?
Ich weiß nicht, worüber sich Linus aufgeregt hat. Ich glaube,
du weißt ganz genau, worüber ich mich aufgeregt habe.
Ja, also genau, das war eine gute Zeit dort und dann habe ich irgendwann...
Warte mal, ist denn das vergleichbar? Sag doch nochmal kurz was zu Peng.
Weil Peng ist ja nun auch so ein bisschen, wir hatten ja jetzt vor kurzem ja
auch das Zentrum für politische Schönheit nochmal zu Gast.
Das ist ja auch so eine wilde Truppe, die, sagen wir mal, Politik mit anderen
Mitteln betreibt. Und ich glaube, das gilt für Peng auch irgendwie. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, sicher. Also was Peng gemacht hat, ist Aktionskunst. Jeder im Kollektiv
und jede hatte eigentlich andere Schwerpunkte.
Die einen sagen Aktionskunst mit Schwerpunkt auf Aktion, die anderen sagen Aktionskunst
mit Schwerpunkt auf Kunst.
Wir haben uns, ein Beispiel war, was für eure Community bestimmt spannend ist, ist Intel Exit.
Da haben wir Geheimdienst-Aussteigerprogramm gestartet, wo ich finde,
das Wichtige ist, dass man Form und Inhalt zusammenbringt.
Also der Versuch in der Aktionskunst ist zu sagen, wir, in dem Fall Geheimdienste,
was machen Geheimdienste?
Die machen Aussteigerprogramme für Linke, Rechte und Islamisten.
Und dann haben wir einen für die gemacht, weil die auch die Demokratie gefährden, oder?
Also für alle, die Demokratie gefährden, Aussteigerprogramme und sind dann mit
einer Drohne über die NSL, also den Stützpunkt da in, wo war das, Darmstadt in der Nelb?
Was heißt das?
Eibling?
Nee, Dingensbummels, ich fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Obwohl er jetzt Politik berichtete.
Ich habe schon eine Beine.
Ich habe viele Fängtaktionen. Ja genau.
Wenn man auf intenexit.org geht, dann findet man auch das Video irgendwie.
Und da sind wir mit einer Drohne drüber geflogen, haben Flyer abgeworfen,
damit die zurückkommen in Demokratie. Der Spruch war dann the backdoor to democracy.
Wir haben schon mit Marketing gearbeitet auch, auch mit diesen ganzen Labels
und wie funktioniert das und das ganze Logo entwickelt und so.
Und dann haben wir Leaks genutzt von Telefonnummern. Das Interessante ist,
bei Geheimdiensten achten ja immer die Leute auf die Pentagon-Papiere und was sind deren Strategien.
Aber keiner kommt auf die Idee, dass die Telefonnummern auch wertvoll sind.
Und die haben wir dann geschröpft und haben dann eine Datenbank aufgebaut mit
Telefonnummern direkt durch Wahlen zu den Leuten, die dort arbeiten.
NSA, aber auch BND und in verschiedensten Abteilungen in Kanada,
in England, GCHQ und überall,
haben dann ein Callcenter aufgebaut im Theater und dann konnten Leute durchwählen
und direkt mit denen kommunizieren.
Und das war so ein bisschen die Idee, diesen Schleier wegzuziehen von diesen
Geheimdiensten, vor denen alle Schiss haben und wollten damit eigentlich sagen,
guck mal, die sind nahbar und wir müssen mit denen die zurückholen und dieses Thema größer machen.
Und auch ein bisschen zu zeigen, dass die sich ja in einer sektenartigen Struktur
befinden, die sich nach außen abkapselt, wo man auch Aussteigerhilfe bieten muss. Ja.
Das Irre war, weil die Frage ist ja, was haben wir denn damit geschafft?
Die gibt es ja immer noch.
Da muss man sagen, die sind jetzt nicht alle ausgestiegen. Es sind super viele
Leute auf uns zugekommen. Das war schon teilweise eine irre Zeit.
Wirklich?
Ja, wir dachten auch, die Chance ist super gering und dann passiert es halt doch.
Und was machst du denn mit denen? Das war schon so ein bisschen ein Problem.
Wir wollten eigentlich nur einen Scherzland-Ruf machen, aber wir wollten sie
mit unserer Psychologe entsprechen.
Wir hatten schon viel vorgebaut. Wir hatten einen ziemlich hohen Sicherheitsstandard.
Wir hatten dann so ein Safe, so ein 350-Kilo-Safe im Büro mit Kameras,
einem eigenen kleinen Server, der die Kameras, damit die nicht gehackt werden können.
Ich bin ein halbes Jahr mit USB-Sticks um den Hals rumgelaufen,
mit Airgap-Laptops rumhantiert. Das war alles neu, da habe ich wirklich viel gelernt.
Ich meine, waren sich die Leute bewusst,
wer diese Kampagne gestartet hat. Ja.
Und die haben gesagt, die Chance ist gering, aber, oder 50-50,
dass ihr für die CIA arbeitet, aber wir wollen es trotzdem versuchen.
Ich habe hier Material, wo kann ich damit hin?
Wir so, äh, Material, äh, Besatzungsjournalisten.
Du kannst uns an Geheimnisse vertrauen.
Aber es war schon irre.
Ich würde auch sagen.
Bis heute, würde ich sagen, ist es eine super Idee gewesen, wenn jemand jetzt
50 Millionen hat, macht ein Aussteigerprogramm für Geheimnismitarbeiter.
Und zwar auf der der menschlichen Ebene, nicht auf der gib mir deine Informationen,
gib denen ein, so wie Courage, hattest du ein bisschen gemacht, Courage von Dächen,
also in die Richtung war es, boah, es war eine krasse Zeit, es war wirklich
total irre und zufällig hat währenddessen auch noch Homeland direkt vor meiner
Haustür gedreht, ja, da waren so plötzlich so Spione mit so Kameras, es war alles surreal,
aber genau, also da haben wir so Aktionskunst gemacht.
Kurzer Nachtrag, ihr seid über den Daggerkomplex geflogen, in Darmstadt an der Grenze zu Griesheim.
Ich hab das schnell Danke. Du hast mir einen Google-Tipp gegeben.
Aber warum habt ihr denn diese Domain intelexit.org nicht behalten?
Ist die weg? Oh Gott.
Da sind jetzt irgendwelche Krypto...
Naja, das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Das muss ja auch finanziert werden. Ja.
Wir sind nicht immer gut gewesen in der Domain-Pflege.
Das stimmt. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen verbrannt.
Aber wenn wir jede Domain behalten hätten, die wir benutzt haben,
dann wären wir jetzt auch Das war echt krass pleite. Also ich bin auch ausgestiegen
bei Peng. Ich bin da gar nicht mehr drin.
Achso, okay, gut. Aber hast du das gemacht und da sozusagen deine Erfahrungen gesammelt?
Ja, da habe ich super viel gelernt. Nee, vor allem eine Sache muss ich an der Stelle doch betonen.
Also ich habe ja ein Buch darüber geschrieben, das ist ja alles öffentlich,
das ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass ich das alles gemacht habe. Nun muss man auch wissen...
Das ist meine Vergangenheit, so wie manche Leute auch zwischendurch mal in der
SPD waren oder so und politisch aktiv waren, habe ich halt sowas gemacht.
Und trotzdem habe ich dann, dann habe ich bei Jörn Böhmermann gearbeitet in
der Redaktion, da wurde es dann schon immer seriöser in Anführungsstrichen.
war eine Satiresendung, aber schon mit einem ziemlichen Ernst im Hintergrund,
da habe ich unter anderem die Hohenzollern-Recherche gemacht und haben wieder
Papiere veröffentlicht aber es eben auf eine bestimmte Art veröffentlicht,
und gesagt, diese Komplexität muss man so,
veröffentlichen, dass es trotzdem eben den Impact hat, den es hat,
weil Hohenzollern alle wegklagt, die irgendwas Kritisches zu ihm machen,
und dann haben wir also da habe ich auch wieder super viel gelernt und habe
mich Stück für Stück weiter gehangelt und ich bin immer noch der Kunst sehr,
sehr verpflichtet, sonst hätte ich jetzt kein Theaterstück gemacht.
Aber jetzt bei Korrektiv ist es ein ganz anderer Schnack.
Hast du nicht auch bei Böhmermann die GPT-3 Nummer damals gemacht?
Boah, also du meinst die KI-Sendung?
KI-Sendung?
Genau, ja, das war als ich gerade mit einem Fuß rausging, das hatte ich angestoßen tatsächlich.
Lass mal eine Sendung nur, Ich kann nicht zu viele interne Details sagen,
aber da habe ich meinen Anteil dran gehabt.
Ja, okay. Ich erinnere mich, dass wir da mal drüber gesprochen haben.
Also okay, Böhmermann ist ja dann schon so eine High-Impact-Recherche kombiniert mit…,
humorvollen Blick drauf, also noch nicht so weit weg von Peng. Genau.
Das war so der Zwischenschritt zwischen Peng und Korrektiv, würde ich sagen.
Also wenn ich jetzt so an meinen Lehrgang sozusagen als Lehrling gucke,
was habe ich gelernt und wie habe ich mich entwickelt?
War denn das eine vergleichbare Tätigkeit?
Wie was? Den Übergang sehe ich jetzt schon.
Also Korrektiv hat jetzt für mich jetzt von außen so den Dünkel des das ist
jetzt der richtige Journalismus so, ja.
Künstlertum, da kann man dann halt drüber streiten und Böhmermann macht ja im
Prinzip auch so eine ähnliche,
so deutsches John Oliver ähm, wir machen jetzt mal ernste Themen aber wir bereiten
sie halt unterhaltsam auf, damit es auch irgendwie ankommt.
Na und Böhmermann hat sich ja selber auch weiterentwickelt. Also das was die
gerade machen ist ja grandios. Das ist ja von, wenn man sich anguckt,
was lief vor zehn Jahren oder was, wie alt ist der denn jetzt schon,
also vor sieben Jahren oder so, das war ja viel mehr Comedy.
Da hatten die die Fernsehhilfe und so, da waren ein paar coole Sachen bei,
dann die Varoufakis und so, das war aber viel mehr. und dann haben die Stück
für Stück, eigentlich fing das so ein bisschen mit hohen Zollern Recherche an
und dann haben die gesagt, wir gehen ins ZDF rüber und ändern das Format und
gehen viel mehr auf Investigativ.
Da haben die ganz neue Leute geholt, Hanna Herbst und wer da alles reinkam,
haben die Rechercheredaktion,
unheimlich aufgestockt und haben da Stück für Stück Standards eingeführt, die wirklich,
ja, also journalistisch sind, einfach viel, viel klarer in diese Richtung gehen
und das war also, damit haben die einen Standard erreicht Und damit haben die
auch Recherchen machen können, wo die gesagt haben,
das hatte ich damals auch angefangen zu sagen, komm lass uns doch mit Leuten
zusammenarbeiten, lass uns doch, da freuen sich und das ist eine Win-Win-Situation,
wenn man mit Frag den Staat zusammenarbeitet, was die jetzt viel machen oder
verschiedenen Gruppen.
anderen investigativen Abteilungen lass uns zusammenlegen, dann werden die auch
gesehen, das ist eine große Plattform, man braucht jetzt nicht immer zu sagen
wir, wir, wir in Konkurrenz sein und das ist ein schönes Modell,
also ich finde das da hat sich ja auch bei denen was entwickelt parallel.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Gewinn, weil man ja eigentlich auch gesehen hat,
bei John Oliver ist schon so ein bisschen eins der Ideen, oder?
So das das Last Week Tonight-Format? Kann man das, darf man das sagen?
Ich glaube, also da gibt es ja Eitelkeiten, da will man ja nicht drüber reden.
Da will ich keine Feinde machen.
Aber es gibt Ähnlichkeiten.
There is only one feeling, will ich jetzt nicht anfassen.
Es könnte schon sein, dass der Böhmermann John Oliver auch schon mal auf YouTube gesehen hat.
Vielleicht.
Es gibt es ja online. Es ist ja auch keine Schande, sich von guten Sachen inspirieren
zu lassen und es steht ja auch vollkommen außer Frage, dass er auch nochmal
eine ganz ganz eigene Persönlichkeit damit einbringt.
Letzten Endes ist es Deutschland, das funktioniert sehr gut.
Singen kann er besser. Ja.
Das stimmt.
Ich habe mir gekauft, Polizistensohn auf Vinyl.
Gibt es das?
Ja.
Habe ich gekauft.
Das ist original, das erste.
Klar, ich habe Polizei und dann noch andere.
Das Recht ist hart. Das ist ja alles diese Gangster-Serie, Polizisten.
Grundy, die Actionfigur von Grundy gab es nicht mehr. Die war schon ausverkauft, als ich den...
Weißt du, woher die kommt, die Grundy-Idee? Das ist von diesem Panda-Bär.
Es gibt so ein Video, so ein Werbevideo im Fernsehen, müssen wir bei YouTube
auch mal rumgoogeln, so ein Panda-Bär, der irgendwann ausrastet und dann im
Dings die ganzen Computer zerhackt.
Und das war eigentlich die Inspiration.
So ein typischer Panda-Kostüm.
Ja.
So ein Panda-Kostüm. und da geht er hin und das war so ein Viral und davon dann,
inspiriert haben wir Grundy gemacht, ja.
Jedenfalls, ich konnte nur noch diese Platte kaufen.
Okay.
Aber bevor wir jetzt anfangen YouTube-Videos zu gucken, der Tim hat dieses YouTube
ohne Werbung, da fällst du noch schneller in das Loch.
Da hängt dir auch eigentlich jeden Abend ein Guck.
Du zahlst für YouTube, bist du Arsch?
Nein. Habe ich dir auch gesagt.
Du gibst Google Geld. Ja. Und also Und zahlst du das mit den Spendengeldern von hier dem Podcast?
Oder was zahlst du direkt weiter an Google?
Klar.
Boah, guck dir das an.
Und Korrektiv.
Alle, die mir irgendwie weiterhelfen.
Wer jetzt noch dabei bleibt, freue ich mich mit euch über die Inhaltsstelle. Genau.
Jetzt kommen wir nämlich zu Korrektiv. Und Korrektiv ist eine...
Das Recherchezentrum, das ist nämlich kein Kollektiv.
Jaja.
Recherchezentrum.
Liegt nah.
Ist aber jetzt auch kein etablierter Begriff oder habe ich was nicht mitbekommen?
Gute Frage. Also es ist auf jeden Fall kein Kollektiv. Wir haben zwei GeschäftsführerInnen,
also das wie gesagt, wir gendern nicht, also zwei GeschäftsführerInnen,
eine Frau ist dabei und das sind David Schraven und Janett Gusko.
Die Janett Gusko ist mit gemeint, ne?
Ach Gott, ey. Ey, bitte jetzt nicht da reingehen. Naja, zu Gender, da kommen wir später zu.
Zu den Gender-Fragen. Gender ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiges Thema für die deutsche Sprache.
Da werden wir noch viel drüber reden, vor allem, weil ich weiß ja nicht,
wie eure Community drauf ist, aber da geht ja immer das Testosteron bei manchen
Männern plötzlich hoch.
Und dann gibt es eine Redaktion, also es ist ein Riesenladen mittlerweile,
also Riesen, nicht so groß wie
der Spiegel, die Zeit, wir haben 100 Leute ungefähr, aber da hast du...
100?
Ja.
Das ist vor weniger als zehn Jahren losgegangen.
Ja, ja.
Also David Straven oder was, der hatte das? Genau.
Der hat das gegründet.
Das ist vor zehn Jahren. Ziemlich genau, ja. 9. Dezember 13.
Und der hat dann noch so irgendwie, also, ja krass.
Also ich erinnere mich, als er dann so, ja hier, wir machen das jetzt und so.
Und David Straven ist ja jetzt kein, also schon ein ernstzunehmender Investigativjournalist
auch vorher schon gewesen. Also man wusste schon, da steckt jetzt was hinter.
Aber das war ja dann eher, wo du dachtest, oh, mal gucken, ob der damit,
und jetzt hat der 100 Leute, gibt's da in dem Laden?
Ich glaub 90, ich weiß nicht genau die Zahl, aber um die 100, ja.
Und du musst aber gucken, die Redaktion selber ist jetzt nicht so groß.
Also du hast 15 InvestigativredakteurInnen, du hast einen großen Teil FaktencheckerInnen
und die sind komplett, ich gender die ganze Zeit.
Mach's doch, wie du willst.
Ich bin Privat hier, ne?
Genau.
Du bist Privat hier. Ich kann gendern, so viel ich will, liebe Linus.
Also dann hast du diese ganzen Faktenchecker in, die machen nichts anderes,
als das Internet aufräumen.
Das ist ein knacke Job. Sie gucken dich die ganze Zeit an.
Die haben nämlich so eine Kooperation dann damals gemacht.
Mit?
Facebook oder Google?
Facebook.
Achso, das heißt, Tims Google-Kohle kommt gar nicht bei euch an.
Da bin ich falsch informiert worden.
Jetzt musst du wieder Werbung gucken.
Da hast du was falsch verstanden. Wir geben ja Facebook kein Geld.
Wir kriegen Geld von Facebook. Also wir knechten Facebook und sagen,
wenn ihr auf uns verzichtet,
Fahren wir euch an den Karren. Das heißt, das ist immer so eine Art Verpflichtungssituation.
Ihr müsst das bezahlen. Genau, Ransomate.
Schönes soziales Netzwerk haben sie da.
Und da wird, also ich meine, das ist halt echt krass, was die da leisten.
Jeden Tag die ganze Scheiße sich anzugucken, zu korrigieren, zu überprüfen und so.
Und das ist aber komplett abgespalten. Ich darf auch gar nicht mit denen zusammenarbeiten.
Also manchmal ist es auch echt nervig, weil ich denke, ihr habt voll Ahnung.
Und die sind so, nee, das wird getrennt.
Und dann gibt es super viele Bildungsangebote, wie die Reporterfabrik,
dann gibt es den Verlag, dann gibt es die Community-Abteilung,
die nichts anderes macht als Social Media.
Und das sind insgesamt um die 90 Leute. Und da ist die Buchhaltung.
Die alle nicht vergessen werden sollten. Okay.
Dann bin ich auch ruhig da, weil tatsächlich jetzt so, sagen wir mal,
die Korrektiv veröffentlicht ja jetzt nicht im Tagestakt.
Bei 100 Leuten würdest du ja schon erwarten, dass die jeden Tag was veröffentlichen.
Aber die Faktenchecker, glaube ich, schon fast.
Aber wenn du jetzt auf korrektiv.org gehst, genau, ja okay, ein bisschen.
Und das hat sich geändert, wir haben jetzt ein Newsletter. Also an der Stelle Werbung, Werbung.
Das ist mittlerweile täglich. Und das ist der Newsletter Spotlight heißt der.
Da kannst du jeden Tag, da kriegst du noch als erster mit, wenn wir so eine
neue Recherche veröffentlichen.
und da wird auch wirklich Tagesgeschehen, da erzählen wir da,
okay, was sind die geilsten, neuesten Recherchen, verlinken zu was weiß ich,
Spiegel und BR und hast du nicht gesehen und kommentieren so ein bisschen auch das Weltgeschehen.
Also versuchen so eine Art Kompass in dieser Wust von Nachrichtenwelt zu sagen,
was ist gerade wichtig und das zusammenzufassen und einen damit zu nehmen. Und das ist täglich.
Und das ändert sich gerade, dass wir immer mehr in Richtung Tagespublikation gehen tatsächlich.
Aber das ist ein Versuch zu gucken, wie macht man das im Internet.
Wir wollen ja nichts printen.
Auf jeden Fall ist das bis hierhin ein recht erfolgreiches Modell gewesen und
ich erinnere mich auch noch ganz gut an die Zeit vor zehn Jahren.
Es gab ja auch ein paar andere Projekte, die ähnlich veranlagt waren.
Der eine fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein, den es nicht mehr gibt.
Krautreporter.
Krautreporter, genau. Riffreporter gibt es noch.
Ich weiß nicht, ja genau.
Krautreporter gibt es auch noch, oder?
Irgendwas hat sich da auf jeden Fall geändert.
Und ich glaube das Wichtige an Korrektiv und das ist das Besondere,
das ist, dass wir gemeinnützig sind. Also es gibt zwei Dinge,
die da glaube ich herausstechen.
Das eine ist die Gemeinnützigkeit, das heißt wir haben alles kostenlos auf der
Webseite, überhaupt keine Werbung, wir sind für Spenden finanziert,
bekommen auch von Stiftungen verschiedenen Geld und so, aber hauptsächlich ist
es Spenden finanziert und dadurch gibt es eine große Unabhängigkeit.
Und ich muss auch sagen, ich merke das selber, wir haben verschiedenste politische
Meinungen bei uns. Also mir wurde noch nie reingeredet, wenn ich irgendwas da bringen wollte.
Und da gibt es also keine sozusagen Linie, wo man irgendwas machen muss oder nicht und so.
Das ist das eine. Und wir sind nicht abhängig sowohl von öffentlich-rechtlichen
Strukturen, die es da gibt.
Und wir haben halt einfach eine Geschäftsführung, die mutig ist.
Das ist total entscheidend, wenn man solche Recherchen macht.
Ich habe gehört aus verschiedenen anderen Redaktionen, die haben das gesehen
und gedacht, ach scheiße, sowas müssen wir eigentlich auch nochmal machen.
Irgendwie sind wir so lahm und sind da in den Bürokratik und ach,
wie kann man das machen und das machen und einfach.
Und das andere ist, dass wir auch schon immer neue Formate gesucht haben,
also von Graphic Novels, wir waren schon oft am Theater und versuchen auch zu
überlegen, wie kann man Journalismus so anders denken, dass es wirklich bei den Leuten ankommt.
Und auch neue Leute erreicht. Also es gibt eine der geilsten Redaktionen bei
uns, sind die Leute von Salon 5, die in fucking Bottrop mit Jugendlichen arbeiten.
Wieso fucking Bottrop? Bottrop ist völlig okay.
Ja, natürlich ist es okay, aber ich war halt bis jetzt selten da.
Und das wird halt auf der Deutschlandkarte übersehen.
Wo ist denn Bottrop?
Bottrop? Ey! In der Nähe von Essen. Da wohnt übrigens unser Geschäftsführer
und fährt immer die Woche nach Berlin.
Und in Bottrop hast du eben die Salon 5 Redaktion.
Und das sind Jugendliche, die sonst irgendwie, was weiß ich,
wo die abhängen würden und da lernen die Journalismus und machen TikTok-Sachen
und so und das, die, eine der coolsten Mitarbeiterinnen bei uns,
Hatice, leitet das und das ist echt, die haben so eine Power, das ist super geil.
Die ist glaube ich gerade TikTok berühmt geworden.
Ist sie?
Na mit, ähm, mit diesem Schminkvideo.
Nee, das ist eine andere glaube ich.
Ach, die ist nicht auch Hatice?
Ach, das war die. Hatice, an der Stelle tut mir leid, weil ich das verpasst
habe, dass du berühmt geworden bist über ein Schminkvideo.
Aber hat die Chip von Talon 5 so viele Knaller?
Dann habe ich das vielleicht gerade verwechselt.
Kannst du mal so ein bisschen schildern, weil mich interessiert jetzt vor allem,
du hast es ja schon angerissen, dass es Unterschiede gibt zu klassischen Redaktionen,
die jetzt in einem Verlag, in einer Zeitschrift oder was auch immer organisiert sind.
Was ist deine Wahrnehmung, wie sich die Struktur von Korrektiv dann ganz praktisch
für arbeitende Journalisten anders entfaltet?
Also fängt das schon bei der Themensuche an oder beim Beschluss?
Wer entscheidet letzten Endes, was gemacht wird? Es wird ja auch da einen Ja-Nein-Prozess
in irgendeiner Form geben.
Also am Ende entscheidet natürlich die Chefredaktion. Du hast Justus van Daniels,
der ist Chefredakteur, stellvertretender Chefredakteur ist Anders Dovideit.
Und da hast du auch noch Corrective Europe, das ist ein anderer Schnack,
also in der Abteilung, wo ich arbeite, in der normalen Reaktion,
hast du sehr flache Hierarchien, du machst Angebote, also es kommen Leute auf
dich zu und irgendwelche Quellen kommen auf dich zu und dann sagst du,
okay, pass auf Leute, ich hab hier was, das ist spannend, das würde ich gerne machen.
Klar muss das diskutieren, wenn es totaler Schmuh ist, dann werden die sagen,
jetzt komme ich schon wieder damit.
Dann muss man sich ein bisschen durchsetzen, wie es halt so ist in Gruppen.
Ist dir das schon mal passiert?
Ist mir schon mal passiert, ja. Das willst du aber nicht sagen.
Womit.
Ich werde das noch bringen, die Große.
Das nagt an meiner Seele, das werde ich noch bringen. Aber ja,
nee, und im Prinzip pitchst du dann Sachen und versuchst durchzubringen,
also wie eigentlich in jeder Gruppe, die irgendwie Bock hat,
geile Sachen zu machen, dass man sich irgendwie diskutiert und das durchsetzt.
Und da ist, erlebe ich aber wirklich viel mehr Förderung als irgendwie Rumgebremse.
Und da hast du natürlich verschiedene Charaktere und so.
Aber es ist gerade, also sonst wäre uns das auch wirklich nicht gelungen mit
dem Ding, muss ich sagen, ein wahnsinnig geiles Team mit unterschiedlichen Qualitäten,
die sich gegenseitig unterstützen.
Ich möchte.
Ey Tim, ich muss ganz kurz sagen, also Bottrop, ne? Bottrop ist als Stadt weltweit
bekannt für eine Kfz-Manufaktur,
die bekannt für ihr für dezenten Auftritt,
hohe Energieeffizienz und insgesamt so ein Understatement ist.
Kennst du? Brabus.
Brabus, das ist ein Mercedes-Benz-Tüter.
Dicke Puschen.
Und Bottrop, da muss ich auch sagen, das Geile ist, wenn du so einen David Schraven
in Bottrop wohnen hast, dann hast du halt ständig Storys in Bottrop.
David Schraven ist so ein Haudegen, der hat dann angefangen,
so einen Kaffeewagen zu machen, weil er Kaffee verkauft hat, noch nebenher.
Und dann kamen die Leute mit Storys auf ihn zu hat angefangen,
da Leute, Journalisten zu engagieren, die Kaffee verkaufen, weil dann so Trauben
sich um den Kaffeewagen gesammelt haben und immer ihre Story.
Und du hast in Bottrop die Apothekengeschichte, ein Riesending,
da hat ein Apotheker gepanschte Krebsmedikamente gemacht und dann hast du die
Papstgeschichte, dass der Papst von Kindesmissbrauch wusste,
hat in Bottrop angefangen.
Das heißt für mich, wenn da du einen so einen fucking Haudegen wie David Schraben
in Bottrop hast, dann brauchst du eigentlich so jemanden, in jeder kleinen Stadt
und dann überall sind diese Geschichten.
Und es kommt noch eine Trilogie, aber darüber darf ich noch nicht reden,
glaube ich. Da kommt noch ein Riesending aus Bottrop.
Also das ist, Bottrop hat schon viel zu bieten.
Und in Bottrop war das Bergwerk Prosperhaniel, da habe ich mal eine Grubenfahrt gemacht und außerdem,
ist da glaube ich, müsste das Walter Extra Flugzeugproduktion,
die das, die weltbekannte,
Kunstflugmaschine machen.
Tim hat keine Ahnung.
Nee, Bottrop ist groß.
Ich habe gelernt, wenn du im Ruhrpott was sein willst, dann musst du auch eine
Mannschaft in der ersten Bundesliga stellen.
Und von Bottrop habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nichts gehört.
Das ist, glaube ich, eher so Einzugsbereich Schalke.
Naja, das ist ja gleich um die Ecke oder nicht. Die gehen doch auch alle auf Schalke.
Aber nochmal kurz zu mich interessiert das. Du hast ja gesagt,
okay, ihr könnt da jetzt besser arbeiten.
Tolles Team. Liegt es jetzt vor allem am Team oder ist es auch so,
dass die Struktur, die sich Korrektiv gewählt hat, da quasi hilfreich ist?
Also Hintergrund der Frage ist sozusagen, ist das ein Modell für Redaktionen?
Also was können Redaktionen von Korrektiv gegebenenfalls? Ja.
Also ich glaube, es kommt ganz viel. Der Fisch stinkt immer vom Kopf her.
Also ich glaube, du hast halt da einen Haudegen an der Spitze,
David Schraven, der, wenn man mit sowas kommt, der sagt, komm, ich habe keine Angst.
Und so ein WDR hat natürlich unheimlich viel Geld und könnte alle Juristinnen
und Juristen der Welt einsetzen, um so eine Geschichte durchzuklatschen.
Aber hat halt viel Angst.
Und deswegen hast du halt, also wir haben ja nur einen Juristen.
Und gehen da volle Kraft rein.
Ich meine, okay, man muss auch sagen, die Beleglage ist extrem gut,
wir haben auch keine großen Sorgen, dass da irgendwas schief geht.
Aber trotzdem muss man damit rechnen, dass sie versuchen einen irgendwie anzugreifen,
haben sie bis heute nicht gemacht,
also nur diese Kraft zu sagen, wir haben keine Angst und wir gehen nach vorne
und wir wollen die Geschichten, die relevant sind irgendwie jagen und machen, das ist erstmal,
da kann man sich drauf verlassen, wir haben den Rückhalt von der Geschäftsführung.
Und dann hast du ein Team, was gewachsen ist.
Ich muss sagen, Justus von Daniels, der ist im Korrektiv, soweit ich das weiß,
der war bei der Zeit auch und so und der ist Jurist.
Aber der ist, und das ist auch ziemlich besonders bei solchen Strukturen,
der ist ein sehr, sehr gewissenhafter Typ, der auch wirklich kein Ego-Schwein ist.
Also es gibt andere Redaktionsleiter, denen geht es am Ende darum,
dass alle ihre Mitarbeiter eigentlich ihre Angestellten sind,
die ihre eigene Person groß machen. Und das ist der überhaupt nicht.
Und bei dem habe ich immer eine sehr fachliche Antwort, eine sehr abwägende
Antwort und ich glaube diese Kombination von einem, der sagt,
komm lass uns nach vorne treiben und der andere sagt, hey lass uns mal alles
abwägen und genau gucken und das nochmal überprüfen und so und ich werde es
wirklich korrekt machen.
Und jetzt könnte ich über jede einzelne Person bei Korrektiv reden, die da was einbringt.
Das ist schon gerade, man redet von geschichtlichen Momentum bei dieser Geschichte.
Ich würde sagen, das ist auch gerade ein sehr schönes, menschliches Momentum
sozusagen, was da zusammengekommen ist.
Also da bin ich, das ist jetzt kein Gelaber, ich fühle mich richtig wohl da.
Goldenen Zwanziger.
Lenus, da sind sie ausgerechnet in Bottrop Bottrop hat übrigens auch eine Skihalle Wirklich?
Bottrop.
Das ist dass du Bottrop nicht kennst Naja.
Mich hat da ehrlich gesagt noch nichts hingetrieben Du.
Warst schon mal in Bottrop Ich war mit dir zusammen in Bottrop Also.
An der Stelle, jetzt habe ich nur zwei Leute rausgehoben die anderen sind natürlich
auch super Wir waren auf dem Petraeder Ach.
Und der ist in Bottrop Der ist in Bottrop.
Das ist das Zentrum der Welt.
Und gutes Bier. Ich habe gehört, die haben eine Brauerei.
Ich habe gar nichts Böses gesagt über Bottrop. Ich habe nur wenig Informationen.
So, dann lass uns doch mal zu dem Geheimplan gegen Deutschland kommen,
der nun für die ganze Aufregung gesorgt hat.
Was kannst du uns denn dazu sagen, wie es dazu kam? Das denkt man sich ja nie
aus, das kriegt man ja irgendwie mit.
Ich muss sagen, relativ klassisch, ehrlich gesagt, im Journalismus.
Da kam eben eine Quelle auf uns zu und da hatten wir eben Briefe.
Briefe, die eingeladen haben dahin. Ich habe nach drei Stunden,
nachdem ich das bekommen habe, ein Zimmer gemietet in dem Hotel.
Da stand nämlich der Ort drin. Da stand drin, dass die hier patriotische Sachen machen wollen und so.
Das Landhaus Adlon in.
Potsdam.
Auch als Gästehaus am Liebnitzsee bezeichnet, also auf der Webseite nennen sie sich selber so Jetzt auf.
Einmal nicht mehr Landhaus Adlon.
Es werden so beide Namen irgendwie bezeichnet.
Aber es bezeichnet dasselbe Es gehört nicht zum Kempinski Adlon,
das ist ja eine Kette, sondern das gehört, es wurde aber gebaut damals von Louis
Adlon in den 20er Jahren als Gästehaus und komischerweise steht nirgendwo im
Internet, was da in der während der Nazi-Zeit war. Das haben wir irgendwie ausgelassen.
Was war denn da? Das weiß ich nicht. Das können Historikerinnen und Historiker
noch herausfinden, wie das da genutzt wurde von den Nazis.
Wir wissen ja, dass Adlon bis zum Ende noch das Zweiten Weltkriegs Gästeempfang hat im Adlon.
Aber ein wunderschönes Haus, also direkt am Leibnizsee.
Leibnizsee. Leibnizsee ist, glaube ich, oben nach Norden.
Genau, einer der schönsten Seen in Leibnizsee.
Nicht verraten.
Geheimer See im Sommer. Nein, ich lenk's nicht mehr.
Genau, der Lenischsee da. Und da habe ich einfach mal Proforma gedacht,
das klingt schon so heiß.
Und dann haben wir einen zweiten Brief bekommen und da war klar,
Martin Sellner soll kommen, Alexander von Bismarck, das stand da alles im Brief.
und es soll um Masterplan gehen und die Kernaufgabe dieses Treffens ist,
Geld zu sammeln für die patriotische Sache.
Da stand ja schon drin in der Einladung.
Ja, da stand alles drin und dass es auch ein neutrales Konto geben soll,
in Anführungsstrichen, auf dem das Geld und man könnte auch so ein Bar bezahlen.
Es roch alles nach so, what the fuck.
Und da haben wir halt gedacht, okay, das ist schon ernst zu nehmen, was die da machen.
und haben uns dann überlegt, wie können wir uns das denn mal genauer angucken.
Also das macht man ja nicht einfach so, ne, das ist nicht irgendwie,
gehst nicht zum Anglerverein und schleust
dich ja ein, sondern weil die ja irgendwie eine kleine Von wann war.
Denn diese Einladung?
Puh, fragst mich was, ich hab die glaube ich im,
September, Oktober bekommen, irgendwie so was und ja, und dann ein Monat später,
war es dann schon soweit. War es dann schon soweit, ja.
Genau, und dann haben wir einen Redakteur da reingeschickt, der eben,
wie gesagt, ich habe das da gebucht, der ist dann da reingegangen und Welches.
Der schönen Zimmer, war es denn?
Das war das hässlichste Zimmer.
Ich dachte.
Hier so Master Suite oder so.
So geht ihr mit den Spenden um?
Die Master Suite, das hat ja der Redakteur da abgefilmt, Der war dann vor Ort
und hat dann mit seinem Handy, lustigerweise in einer bestimmten Situation,
gab es da Briefe, die aufgestapelt waren am Morgen des Treffens.
Und der ist da rumgelaufen und hat da die ganze Zeit nach Kaffee gefragt und
gesagt, ich bin hier auch Gast und ich will irgendwie Kaffee haben und frühstücken und so.
Und dann stand da plötzlich, lagen da ganz viele Briefe aufgestapelt mit den
Namen drauf, der Leute, die kommen.
Ja und der war, offensichtlich hat er das da gefilmt und da sah man Ulrich Siegmund
übernachtet in der Master Suite und das war der Fraktionsvorsitzende von Sachsen-Anhalt, der AfD.
Das heißt, der war deren kleiner Star.
Und der hat das teuerste Zimmer bekommen?
Der hat das geilste Zimmer bekommen mit Swimmingpool und was da alles.
Meinst du, der hat das selber bezahlt?
Nicht Swimmingpool, Whirlpool. Kein Plan.
Ab 200 Euro steht hier.
Ach, ab!
Also wir wissen, dass der Hausbesitzer offensichtlich auch ein bisschen Probleme im Finanzamt hat.
Da haben wir Dokumente.
Bedauerliches Missverständnis.
Ja, der hat wohl ziemlich viel Schulden.
Oder weiß ich nicht, ob er Schulden
hat. Er zahlt auf jeden Fall nicht rechtzeitig seine Steuer bezahlt.
Das hat er einfach so rumliegen lassen, die ganzen Sachen. Achso.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wo habt ihr das denn jetzt schon wieder her?
Ja, lag alles rum. Das lag alles in diesem Hotel rum, offen.
Also von Infosec hat der offensichtlich überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Das war sowieso Infosec-mäßig sehr lustig. Ja.
Dass da überhaupt noch andere Zimmer verfügbar waren, das finde ich ja schon krass.
Da vermute ich ehrlich gesagt einen Verpeiler und auch eine Unprofessionalität,
dass wenn die so ein Ding machen, die Leute einfach sich bei Booking.com einbuchen
lassen, also über die Webseite ging es wohl nicht mehr, aber über Booking.com ging es noch.
War nicht alles schlecht.
Ich würde ja an deren Stelle sagen, entschuldigen Sie bitte,
wir sind überbucht und wir buchen Ihnen ein anderes Geschenk,
ein anderes Zimmer irgendwo in Potsdam. Haben Sie nicht gemacht.
und dann war ja auch die Betonung.
Ausgebucht und trotzdem da, booking.com Antifa.
Und dann haben wir, naja, wir sind ja seriöse Journalisten, wir sind kein Antifa,
wir machen natürlich Redaktionsarbeit und da war aber auch in der,
in diesem Moment der Konferenz, es gab so ein Moment, das muss ich erzählen,
wegen dieser Infosec-Geschichte,
dass der sich einen ganz stolz gesagt hat, ich mach hier alles nur per Post.
Also, Also das ist ganz wichtig, dieser Gernot Möhring, das war der Organisator
zusammen mit Hans-Christian Limmer.
Von denen waren also diese Briefe?
Genau, der erste Brief war unterschrieben von Hans-Christian Limmer,
der ist groß geworden, hat sehr viel Geld verdient mit Backwerk.
Es hat ja einen Verkauf für um die 100 Millionen.
Die Bäckereikette. Die Bäckereikette.
Auf Bäckereikette.
Auf Bäckereikette, ja.
Das ist schon interessant, dass die ganzen Lebensmittelunternehmer,
Müller und so und noch ein anderer, die machen alle so Nahttiere.
Und dann hat der die Pottsalat,
die haben super reagiert, die machen so Lieferservice für gesundes Essen.
Da hat er investiert. Willst du die durchsetzen?
Die machen das richtig, die haben ihr Logo geändert mit so einem gegen Nahtzucker.
Ja, ja, ich hab das gesehen auf LinkedIn, damit er direkt so ein Gegen-Nazi-Symbol
nämlich bei sich hatte. Ja, ja.
Ja. Und dann Hans im Glück, die Burgerkette und wir beide haben jetzt gesagt,
bitte geh hier raus, das ist nicht so gut für unser Marketing,
dass du hier so eine Nazi-Konferenz machst.
Und die beiden haben eingeladen und es ist schon interessant,
da Gernot Möhrig, das ist so ein Zahnarzt aus Düsseldorf gewesen,
zu dem Zeitpunkt schon in Rente.
Und hat also eingeladen und hat dann vor der ganzen Konferenz,
ja bitte alles nur per Post und dieses ganze Telegram und Whatsapp,
das ist alles viel zu gefährlich und so und lass uns bitte keine digitalen Sachen.
weil Anon Leaks, die nämlich schon mal irgendwas zu denen veröffentlicht hat.
Und das haben wir dann auch gefunden.
Also Anon Leaks hatte schon mal so ein Düsseldorfer Forum, so hieß dieses Treffen von denen,
interne E-Mails veröffentlicht, wo Topala auch irgendwie drin vorkam und irgendwie
ein Konto von Ute und Thomas und so. Das war alles schon da drin.
Und dann sagt er alles bitte nur per Brief, alles nur per Post.
Aber der kommt nicht auf die Idee, dass es noch den Human Factor gibt,
der diese Briefe einfach weitergibt.
So hatten wir halt diese Briefe.
Und konnten das einschätzen und haben gesagt, okay, das ist schon relevant.
Was da passiert, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Vor allem, weil das jetzt, wir sind gerade über Martin Sellner so relativ schnell
hinweggegangen, aber der ist ja wirklich einer der bekanntesten,
Neonazis. Ja.
Das muss man sagen. sagen, der ist halt ein Marketing-Stratege.
So würde ich ihn beschreiben.
Der arbeitet mit Worten. Und die arbeiten, die sagen halt, lasst uns nicht Neonazis
nennen, lasst uns Identitären nennen.
Lasst uns nicht über Rassen sprechen, lasst uns über Ethnien sprechen.
Lasst uns, also das ist immer sozusagen das Wording, lasst uns nicht über Deportationen
und sowas, lasst uns über Remigration sprechen.
Also das ist, wir versuchen, ein Gewand anzuziehen mit schönen Lambda-Zeichen
und so statt Hakenkreuz und damit wird eine völkische Ideologie verbreitet.
Österreicher.
Den haben wir schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
Hat auch ein Kunstverständnis, muss man sagen. Also das ist genau Österreicher mit Kunstverständnis.
Er hätte nicht Maler werden können.
Wer weiß.
Er hat noch eine Chance.
Vielleicht wurde er schon abgelehnt.
Also er ist schon in der Lage, sich sortiert auszudrücken. Ja.
Durchaus, sag ich mal, jetzt ein Bildungsstand, der höher ist als der durchschnittliche Neonazi.
Hier steht jetzt auf Wikipedia nicht, dass er ein Neonazi ist.
Insofern sagen wir mal, er ist ein rechtsextremer Aktivist und Autor.
Laut Wikipedia.
Als Sohn eines Homöopathen und einer Englischlehrerin in Baden bei Wien aufgewachsen.
Als Jugendlicher schloss er sich der Neonazi-Szene an. Okay.
Und oh je, oh je, oh je.
Boah, das willst du gar nicht lesen, ne? Also ein wirklich, hatte eine,
sagen wir mal, schwere Kindheit.
Kannst du die Schleppergeschichte von dem?
Nee.
Das ist eine wunderschöne Anekdote. Der hat dann irgendwann dieses,
gegen die Seenotrettung, ein Schiff gechartert und hat dann irgendwie so Flaggen
gehalten vor den den Seenotrettern.
Und dann dieses Schiff, was sie gechartert haben, das waren Tamilen auf dem Schiff. Und dann,
sind die nämlich angelandet. Es ist alles total monströs schief gelaufen.
Da hat überhaupt nichts erreicht.
Und dann haben die, als sie angelandet sind, sind dann die ganzen Tamilen von
Bord gegangen und haben gesagt, okay, Asyl!
Und dann...
Das war diese komplett gescheiterte Mission, jaja.
Ne, also genau, der ist halt im Geiste des Neonazitums, völkischen Dingen und
der hat dann dieses Buch geschrieben,
was bei Götz Kubitschek veröffentlicht wurde, was im Doppelpack verkauft wird
mit Maximilian Krah und wenn man sich diese, das wird ja nicht aus Zufall im
Doppelpack verkauft, Maximilian Krah ist AfD, EU-Kandidat gerade,
also ziemlich weit oben, ehemals CDU Und der sagt in seinem Buch,
und das haben wir uns natürlich alle
durchgelesen, was ist deren Argumentationslinie, im Buch von Krah steht,
die wollen 25 Millionen, der zahlt 25 Millionen Menschen müssen aus Deutschland raus.
Also das ist so sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, ob der sagt aus Deutschland raus,
aber es geht um 25 Millionen.
Und Selna… Das Land erledigt.
Das ist komplett klar.
Also wenn wir nicht ein paar Tamilen noch dazukriegen.
Nee, also im Ernst, da geht es ja wirklich um uns alle.
Das ist nicht nur die 25 Millionen, sondern da geht es, und das muss man verstehen, es geht um uns alle.
Und Sellner beschreibt dann die Strategie dazu in seinem Buch und da finde ich
ganz interessant, der hat einen Artikel über Militanz, wo er beschreibt, was alles nicht geht.
Also der beschreibt sozusagen die militante Strategie und schreibt darunter
den kuriosen Satz, aber das müssen
wir natürlich aus grundsätzlichen oder prinzipiellen Gründen ablehnen.
Und das heißt, diese Fantasie von Bürgerkrieg, von wirklich gewaltvollem Umsturz,
die wird dort angerissen und immer in einer Fantasie beschrieben,
aber das geht natürlich nicht.
So wie Höcke sagt, der kommende Bürgerkrieg, Selner hat jetzt auch nach der
Veröffentlichung von dem kommenden Bürgerkrieg gesprochen. Also die fantasieren
einen gewaltvollen Umsturz und immer so in Klammern.
Ja und versuchen das natürlich rechtlich immer so zu sagen, dass es irgendwie noch klar geht.
Aber glaubst du, dass er,
also ich hab's nicht geschafft, sowas zu lesen, also ich wüsste auch nicht,
wo ich das herbekomme, ohne dass der ein Center verkriegt, ja.
Aber meinst du, dass er eigentlich sich für einen gewaltsamen Umstoß interessiert oder dass er sich für die,
faschistischen Ziele interessiert und eher denkst du, lass mal den althergebrachten
Weg, die originalen Nazis haben es auch ohne Gewalt geschafft.
Nee, das ist strategisch. Also der bezieht sich interessanterweise auf Gramsci,
den Postmarxisten, der im Knast war und da seine Bücher geschrieben hat.
Und Gramsci hat ja von den organischen Intellektuellen gesprochen,
von seinem Kulturkampf, in Graben kämpfen, dass man...
Antonio G-R-A-M-S-C-I.
Genau, Antonio Gramsci.
Das ist ein Sarde.
Der hat eben diesen Kulturkampf beschrieben und den beschreibt der Selner als Metapolitik.
Darum ging es auch sehr viel bei der Konferenz. Also wie kann man eine Stimmung
schaffen, in der, wenn die Nazis an der Macht sind, die Bevölkerung mitzieht.
Darum ging es. Das ist Teil dieses sogenannten Masterplans. Also er selber hat
es nicht Masterplan genannt, sondern der Gernot Möhrig hat es Masterplan genannt,
in den Briefen und auch in der Konferenz.
und Sellner war dann ganz berührt, ach das würde ich jetzt wohl nicht sagen
und so Ich bin doch kein Master Ich bin.
Doch noch gar nicht Master.
Der Master Suite war ja der Ulrich Dings, der Musikmund Ja und das also,
Dann geht es um die vorpolitischen Raum, der kulturell geschaffen werden muss.
Die beziehen sich da, muss man auch sagen.
Also betonen den Erfolg, wenn Olaf Scholz sagt, wir wollen hier ganz viel abschieben und so.
Also so eine Stimmung zu schaffen. Und da muss ich auch sagen,
die Parteien, die jetzt weiter, weil bei der Einführung der Konferenz wurde
gesagt, das, worum, was, wo wir jetzt drauf müssen, ist Migration.
Und die haben dann dekliniert und gesagt, alles, was Ukraine,
was Israel, was Corona und so angeht, das spaltet uns nur.
Aber wo wir zusammenstehen, ist das Migrationsthema. Und wenn man sich anguckt,
wie wichtig ist denn Migration?
Also jetzt gerade dieses neue Gesetz von der Ampel, wo die Abschiebungen erleichtern sollen.
Manche nennen es das Ausländer-raus-Gesetz.
Das soll nichts erleichtern, das ist eine Verbesserung. Rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz. Genau.
Und dieses Rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz, da geht es ja darum,
von wie vielen Menschen reden wir da.
Da geht es ja darum, Menschen abzuschieben, die, wenn ich das jetzt richtig
im Kopf habe, die nicht ausreisewillig, aber ausreisefähig sind und auch keine
Aufenthaltserhöhungen haben. Das sind maximal 100.000 Menschen.
Und diese 100.000 Menschen, die liegen uns ja gar nicht auf der Tasche.
Die sind ja gar nicht erfasst. Das heißt, sie kriegen kein Geld vom Sozialstaat.
Diese 100.000 Menschen, um die schneller abzuschieben, müssen wir so viele Grundrechte opfern.
Also da werden Kinder nachts aus der Wohnung geholt.
Privatsrecht, Schutz des Kindes und so weiter. Diese ganzen Grundrechte werden
über Bord geworfen, um irgendwie ein Zeichen zu setzen,
dass man jetzt schneller abschieben kann das ist schon sehr sehr problematisch
und gleichzeitig muss man trotzdem
sagen und das ist jetzt eben der Schulterschluss zum bürgerlichen Lager,
Hier in dieser Konferenz ging es um deutsche Staatsangehörige.
Da ging es um Menschen, die in zweiter, dritter Generation hier leben,
die dieses Land aufgebaut haben nach dem Krieg.
Und da sagte der Sellner eben an einem entscheidenden Punkt,
als rückgefragt wurde aus dem Publikum, ja was machen wir mit denen,
die einen Pass haben? Dann hat er ja, das ist ganz schwierig,
das ist das größte Problem.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es wörtlich zitiere gerade, aber es steht alles im Text.
Aber da müssen wir mit maßgeschneiderten Gesetzen einen hohen Anpassungsdruck
schaffen und dann Stück für Stück die raus. Wenn man in seinem Buch schaut,
dann sagt er nochmal ganz deutlich, die Methoden findet man in der Bewegung.
Wenn man sich die Bewegung der Neonazis anguckt, dann sind das Gewaltmethoden.
Und dann redet er noch über Bürgerkrieg und so weiter. Also natürlich wird es mit Gewalt gehen.
Natürlich ist es keine schöne Sache, wie der Höcke irgendwann sagt,
es wird auch irgendwann mal wehtun und so.
Also, aber die Sprache, die sie nutzen, ist sehr gewählt.
Und wenn man jetzt nochmal, jetzt mache ich das doch auch, selbst wenn das jetzt
nicht Leute waren von der Wandling-Konferenz, weil die nicht an der Macht waren,
das waren Menschen, die nicht an der Macht waren, aber die hatten diese Möhre
der Macht vor ihrem Gesicht.
Wir gehen trotzdem mal kurz zur Wandling-Konferenz und schauen uns die Protokolle
an und da steht auch drin, alles was hier passiert, muss auf legalem Wege passieren.
Das stand ganz explizit in den Dokumenten der Wandling-Konferenz.
Alles muss legal sein. Und ich würde auch sagen, alles muss demokratisch sein.
Nazis wurden demokratisch gewählt.
Also demokratisch und legal ist kein Maßstab, um zu sagen.
Geht's oder geht's nicht. Wenn du anstrebst, die Regierung zu stellen,
dann definierst du ja einen großen Teil von legal.
Ganz richtig. Jetzt haben wir ein Grundgesetz, du kannst ja nicht einfach so
über das Verfassungsgericht drüber fliegen, selbst als Regierung.
Die fängt ja auch regelmäßig ein, wie wir gerade gesehen haben mit dem Klimadingster.
da, aber die überlegen sich schon genau, wie können wir das schaffen. Und,
Ich glaube, weil viele Leute auch reagiert haben mit der Mensch,
irgendwie ist es ja nichts Neues, das stimmt auch, in vielerlei Hinsicht ist
es nichts Neues, steht in deinem Buch, steht bei KRA, steht bei Selna,
wir wissen, schon seit langem gibt es Neonazis.
Und die AfD ist eine sehr rassistisch geprägte Partei, die in vielen Teilen
rechtsextrem ist, aber was da passiert ist, war in dem Sinne neu,
dass die Kombination von allem im Brennglas dann sehr deutlich ausgesprochen wurde.
Und da saßen jetzt im Publikum, also ich meine, wenn man Martin Sellner reden
hören will, der ist ja durchaus beschäftigt, sich in sozialen Medien zu verbreiten,
du hast gesagt, der hat Bücher geschrieben.
Ein Buch hat er geschrieben und ein anderes hat er mitgeschrieben. So.
Und jetzt sitzt er da in dieser Runde, wo ja ein bisschen andere Bedingungen herrschen.
Es gibt den Aufruf oder die Aufforderung, relativ viel Geld zu spenden.
Es wird von irgendwelchen Multimillionären geladen.
Es ist eine Mischung an Leuten da. Vielleicht können wir einmal ganz kurz so ein...
kurzen Überblick über die Leute uns verschaffen, die so da waren.
Dass wir mal so schauen, wir haben diesen Limmer, der hat seine Kohle mit mit
dem Backwerk gemacht und ist jetzt Gesellschafter bei Pottsalat und Hans im Glück.
Der ist rausgeflogen. Der rausgeflogen ist auch ein feines Wort,
die haben natürlich viel Cash gezahlt. Die mussten den ja rauskaufen.
Das fand ich auch. Also ich meine, der hat jetzt einfach nur,
Also der wird seine Anteile jetzt verkauft haben oder verkaufen.
Man muss an der Stelle auch sagen, bevor jemand 100 Millionen in die Hand nimmt
und das jemandem gibt, für Backwerk zum Beispiel, das kennen die denn nicht?
Also das fand ich schon erschreckend, dass die Gesellschafter von Backwerk nicht
sagen, ich gucke mir das mal an.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob bei finanziellen Investoren ein politischer Backgroundcheck,
Ich glaube, die geben sich sehr viel Mühe, die Zahlen zu checken.
Ja, offensichtlich. Das ist das Problem.
Falls ihr mal in der Lage sein solltet, irgendwem 100 Millionen Euro zu geben,
guckt doch einfach mal, ob das ein richtig harter Neonazi ist.
Kommt in den besten Familien vor.
Wobei ich jetzt sagen würde, wenn der die 100 Millionen nicht bekommen hätte,
hätte, dann hätte er sie früher oder später mit diesem Backwerk verdient.
Auch das Kapital kauft dir das Ding ja nicht ab für mehr, als es wert ist.
Na gut, aber das ist eine andere Diskussion. Okay.
Also jetzt haben wir den Limmer. Der war nicht da.
Der war nicht vor Ort.
Ach, der war nicht vor Ort?
Nee, der hat aus ganz unwisslichen Gründen abgesagt. Der hat eingeladen.
Ist der eure Quelle oder was?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Das wäre ja der Hammer.
Hat der das echt? Nein, das gibt's doch nicht.
Ich hab ne Idee, wer die Quelle ist.
Vielleicht hat er bessere Quellen gehabt als die anderen. Also das kann ja auch sein.
Okay, gut, der war jetzt nicht da, der hat das nur aber der hat Einladungsschreiben versendet.
Der hat zumindest die Unterschrift drunter und wir haben ihn auch gefragt,
warum haben sie denn die Unterschrift nicht versagt oder ich weiß nicht genau,
wie die Frage war, aber sie haben doch unterschrieben, darauf hat er nicht reagiert.
Und der hat das alles rüber geschoben an den Gernot Möhrig, der andere Einladende.
Ne, der hat es nicht rübergeschoben, der hat den Brief mit unterschrieben.
Und der Gernot Möhrig, der, da habe ich auch was vorliegen, was noch nicht veröffentlicht wurde.
Oh, ein NLP-Exclusive. Wo ist der passende Trigger? Das haben wir gar nicht.
Ich lese mal vor, aus der Stellungnahme, also, ich habe jetzt an der Stelle,
muss ich sagen, vermutliche Stellungnahme aus dem Freundeskreis von Gernot Möhrig.
Das habe ich nicht überprüfen können, können, ob die wirklich von ihm stand,
aber die ist angeblich vom 12.01.2024 und da sagt er, Stellungnahme von Gernot
Möhrig, soll ich das ganze Ding vorlegen?
Wir haben Zeit. Okay.
Also Stellungnahme von Gernot Möhrig zum privaten Treffen 25.11.2023 in Potsdam.
Es handelte sich um ein privates, parteiunabhängiges Treffen,
zu dem ich postalig eingeladen hatte.
Insofern war nicht die Zusammenkunft geheim, sondern lediglich die groß angelegten,
illegalen massiven Abhörmaßnahmen von Seiten von Korrektiven.
Ich weiß nicht, was er meint.
Aber dann sagt er als nächstes, da die meisten Teilnehmer aus reinem Informationsinteresse
an den privaten Treffen teilgenommen haben, gab es auch keine Teilnahmenberechtigung von 5000 Euro.
Wir wissen mittlerweile, also im Brief stand 5000 Euro, bitte mitmachen.
Und einer der AfD-Teilnehmer haben auch bestätigt, er hat 5000 Euro bezahlt.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass nicht alle das bezahlt haben.
Nächster Punkt. Die anwesenden Unternehmer, Politiker, Journalisten brachten
die Frage zusammen, wie die auf vielen Gebieten katastrophalen politischen Entwicklungen
in Deutschland korrigiert werden können.
Dazu sollte ein Masterplan diskutiert werden.
Also bestätigte unsere Recherche hier. Ein Thema war dabei, wie mit den zigtausend
in Deutschland illegal lebenden Ausländern zu verfahren sei.
Es gab keinen Abschiebemaßplan.
Korrektiv hat völlig korrekt berichtet, dass ich die Bildung einer Expertengruppe
für die Zukunft angeredet habe, damit unter ethischen, rechtlichen und logistischen
Gesichtspunkten die Frage erörtert werden sollte,
wie hier rechtswidrig anwesende und kriminelle auffällig gewordenen Ausländer
aus der Landes gebracht werden können.
Also dieses Logistische muss ich mir auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
das bestätigt er hier nochmal.
Dabei ist für mich völlig klar, dass Deutsche mit Migrationsgeschichte,
die sich konstruktiv einbringen, überhaupt kein Thema für diese angedachte Expertengruppe
sein können. Der hat übrigens für die Expertengruppe angeregt,
dass Hans-Georg Maaßen da mitmachen soll.
Daher wurde auch zu keinem Zeitpunkt die, Anführungsstriche,
Vertreibung von Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland einschließlich deutscher
Staatsbürger diskutiert, geschweige denn der Begriff Deportation erwähnt.
Der Begriff Deportation wurde tatsächlich erwähnt, das stimmt. Stimmt.
Und die sagen ja Remigration.
Die sagen Remigration. Und die deutschen Staatsbürger wurden aber sehr wohl genannt.
Und die vielen Falschmeldungen über meine Person nehmen zur Zeit täglich derart
zu, sodass ich dazu aktuell nicht im Einzelnen Stellung beziehen kann.
12.1.2024 Dr. Gernot Möhrig.
Also das wurde mir zugespielt aus dem Umfeld von Gernot Möhrig.
Ich kann es, muss ich dazu noch mal sagen, können wir nicht überprüfen,
ob es wirklich von ihm ist.
Können wir uns gleich mal die Metadaten der PDF angucken.
Der Begriff Remigration steht ja jetzt in dieser ganzen Geschichte ziemlich
groß geschrieben da, weil er halt sozusagen als Talking Point hier ja extrem gepusht wurde.
Und es ist ja auch wieder so eine, der Versuch so einer Umdeutung.
Weil es ja an sich ein entstehender Begriff ist, ganz normal.
Das ist ein soziologischer Begriff.
Migration, es gibt auch Leute, die migrieren irgendwo hin, dann migrieren sie
wieder zurück, dann ist das Remigration.
Das ist aber ein freiwilliger Vorgang und hier ist ja eigentlich von einer etwas
weniger freiwilligen Remigration die Rede. Ja.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass der unterschiedlich benutzt wird.
Hier wurde der schon ziemlich klar benutzt, aber im Prinzip hätte ich jetzt
vor zwei Monaten oder drei nicht gesagt, dass jeder Mensch, der dieses Wort
benutzt, damit meint, dass die Leute gewaltvoll aus dem Land gedrängt werden.
Mein Eindruck ist schon, dass da hier, also gerade mit dieser Sache von deutschen
Staatsangehörigen, das doch deutlich wurde.
Also der Ulrich Siegmund hat in seinem Vortrag dort auch davon gesprochen,
wie, also ich habe den Eindruck, das war eigentlich so ein, der hat so das Bild
von so einem Germania Disneyland gehabt.
Also von so einem Land, in dem irgendwie, ja,
also wir wollen zeigen, wie toll das ist, wenn hier nur noch Deutsche rumhängen
und so, die Bio-Deutsch sind,
solche Worte nutzen wir natürlich auch nicht, aber da ging es darum, dass sie Druck machen.
Und das hat mich daran erinnert, was die in Dortmund-Dorstfeld gemacht haben.
Also in Dortmund-Dorstfeld, wenn ich, ich kann vielleicht googeln nochmal,
ob ich das richtig gesagt habe, waren die so Nazi-Kids.
Da hatten die eine national befreite Zone.
Dortmund nicht unwahrscheinlich.
Und guck mal hier, national befreite Zone.
Gerade ein Rechtsextremist, ein Blogger von Rechtsextremisten angegriffen worden, dadurch ja.
Auf jeden Fall ein Statut von Dortmund, da kam, soweit ich das verstanden habe,
das Bürgeramt hat gesagt, ey, hier, guck mal hier,
da ist dann fehlten Feuerlöcher und hier Baumaßnahmen, die Treppe ist irgendwie
nicht ordentlich und dann jeden Tag sind die gekommen und das hat die Nazis
schon ziemlich geärgert.
Also damit drängt man eben Menschen aus einem einen bestimmten Kiez raus.
Und in die Richtung ging auch die Fantasie zu sagen, lass uns doch mal zu den
Dönerläden gehen und denen richtig auf die Nerven gehen.
Kriegen die alle eine Steuerprüfung? Dann gucken wir nochmal.
Und der Ordnungsamt muss auch noch in der Hygiene gucken.
Genau. Also das und dann...
Der sanfte Terrorismus der Bürokratie. Ja.
Und was sehr wenig aufgegriffen wurde, natürlich weil du es auch schwer belegen
kannst, das war eine Fantasie von dem, aber der hat schon sehr deutlich gesagt,
ich brauche sehr viel Geld.
Und dieses Geld, das möchte ich gerne individuell mit euch besprechen,
wie das zu mir kommt, aber ich habe da so eine Idee.
Also er hat gesagt, er braucht 1,37 Millionen Euro.
Das wird jetzt alles ein bisschen hektisch in meiner Erzählung,
weil ich jetzt hin und her springe, aber ich fand diesen Teil von Ulrich Siegmund,
dass über Spendengelder so wenig gesprochen wurde im Nachgang,
interessant, weil das wurde, eigentlich ist das schon relevant nach so vielen
Spendenskandalen von der AfD.
Da sagt er, ja, ich weiß ja, über Spenden ist das der sauberste Weg,
aber man kann ja zum Beispiel, ist jetzt nicht wörtlich, aber man kann ja zum
Beispiel über Personalgeschichten oder Agenturen andere Wege finden.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich mache hier für Logbuch-Netzpolitik,
ich habe da einen Freund, den bezahle ich direkt und der schiebt dir,
Linus, die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Arbeiten zu.
Der macht Recherche, der macht Dings, der engagiert auch eine Agentur,
die macht irgendwie riesige Werbekampagnen für Logbuch-Netzpolitik.
Damit habt ihr nichts zu tun, dann geht das Geld ja nicht über eure Bücher und
trotzdem geht das Geld zu deinem Gunsten.
Dann sollten wir uns mal drüber unterhalten.
Die Idee ist eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Halt.
Ja, da sind die Deutschen aber anständig und berichten nicht darüber,
solange man es nicht belegen kann.
Lass uns noch mal so ein bisschen beim Line-Up bleiben, dass man es jetzt nicht
zu sehr, also nicht sofort in diesem gesamthematischen Ding findet.
Der Möhrig hat aber seine ganze Familie mitgebracht.
Genau.
Nee, nee, nee.
Hat der noch viel mehr Familie?
Nee, der hat noch viel mehr. Der war nur sein Sohn, Arne Friedrich Möhrig.
Ja.
Aber der war ja ganz stolz, dass seine ganze Familie alles Nazis sind.
Ja, der war ganz stolz, dass er im sechsten Lebensjahr dabei ist.
und der hat also tatsächlich, der hat, da kamen auch sehr viele Hinweise jetzt
seitdem rein über die anderen Familienmitglieder also der hat noch zwei Töchter
und ich glaube der hat auch noch einen Sohn, ich bin mir ganz sicher und der hat dann auch die,
Schwiegerkinder die angeheiratet sind, auch alle.
Hat er auch alle konvertiert alle rechts. Und die Astrid Möhrig ist die,
die die Umschläge entgegennehmen sollte?
Das ist seine Frau, genau Genau, die auch in der Düsseldorfer Society irgendwie viele Freunde hat.
Zum Beispiel die Ex-Frau von Boris Becker, mit dem war die Barbara.
Welche?
Barbara.
Glaube ich heißt die.
Barbara Becker.
Barbara Becker. Da habe ich zumindest ein Foto von denen gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die befreundet sind, aber es gibt so ein Foto.
Barbara Becker, wenn du Astrid Mürig, Barbara Becker eingibst, dann findest du die.
Die wollen den nicht, der Boris.
Und die sind wirklich rumgelaufen durch die Düsseldorfer Society und haben sich
ja getroffen mit allen möglichen.
Wagenknecht hat ja auch jetzt bei Markus Landt gesagt, jo, den hat sie getroffen,
die war mit dem Abendessen. Volker Pispos war mit dem Abendessen.
Was im Moment?
Ja. Ja, ja. Der ist so ein Typ. Das habe ich jetzt verstanden,
erst nach der Wagenknecht-Sendung. Da haben sich nämlich verschiedene Leute bei uns gemeldet.
Und der guckt eine Sendung und dann sieht der, ey, die ist gut für den langfristigen Kampf.
Da war eine Frau, die war so gut integriert aus einem anderen Land und die hat
sich für Abschiebungen von kriminellen Ausländern bei einer populären Sendung,
ich will die jetzt ein bisschen schützen, weil irgendwie sind die auf den Rhein gefallen.
Da hat er sofort angeschrieben, ganz höflich, ganz nett und so und lassen Sie
uns mal treffen, ich will die jemand vorstellen und so.
Bis heute hatte ich keine Ahnung, was für ein krasser Rechtsradikal der ist.
Und die hat mich angerufen und die hat mir so viel erzählt über den.
Die hat mich dann verbunden mit anderen Freunden von denen und so.
und das war schon, also der ist das war so sein Typ, wirklich also ich hab den
ja auch da bei Youtube gesehen und so und der ist ein super freundlicher,
netter Typ gewesen, total korrekt,
und hat ja lange eine Bezahnerspraxis gehabt und ist da auch Kongressen gewesen und so,
und ist immer sehr freundlich auf Leute zugegangen, hat gesagt wir lassen uns
Abendessen und wollte netzwerken, netzwerken netzwerken, netzwerken und aus
diesem Netzwerk hat er dann eben diese Veranstaltung gemacht,
Wo dann sein Sohn auch eine Agentur gepitcht hat und der Sellner seinen Plan
und der Siegmund seinen Plan und der Vosgerau, der Anwalt.
Also so, jetzt gehen wir mal auf die Leute. Wer war dabei?
Aus der AfD selber war als kleines Licht Tim Krause aus Kreis Potsdam.
Keine Ahnung, wie er sich da verloren hat.
Der ist auch mal zum Islam konvertiert und der ist anscheinend ein Grün-Typ.
Wenn ich genau weiß, was das ist.
Ist wieder regentiert. Ja, ist wieder offensichtlich zurück zur AfD.
Also es wurde mir gesagt. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Aber gut,
und dann hat der war der andere Ulrich Siegmund.
Den hatten wir ja schon. Den hatten wir ja schon.
Genau.
Der hier seinen ganzen Spenden-Pitch da gemacht hat. Und der Master Suite war.
Und dann hatten wir Gerrit Hui.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Name?
Hui. Ich hab mich auch gefragt, was machst du, wenn die an der Macht ist?
Heil Hui. Heil Hui. Das kannst du doch nicht machen.
Oh Mann, das ist ja, okay, aber Hui. Aber das ist doch kein,
da würde ich doch jetzt erstmal einen Migrationshintergrund vermuten.
Gerrit Hui. Gerrit Hui ist auch sehr erbost über unsere Veröffentlichung. Gut.
Ich würde jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich, ich würde jetzt erstmal davon ausgehen,
dass alle, die relativ erbost sind.
Und dann, ich sag mal, der spannendste von all dem ist Roland Hartwig.
Denn Roland Hartwig, ehemaliger Chefjurist von Bayer-Konzern,
das ist keine kleine Nummer,
der hat sich damals solidarisch zu Kalbitz verhalten, als Kalbitz aus der AfD
geflogen ist. muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen.
Kalbitz, Fraktionsvorsitzender von AfD Brandenburg.
Der wurde gesichtet bei einem Lagertreffen von,
den, ich weiß nicht, nicht der Sportgruppe Hoffmann, sondern der Bund Deutscher
Also ich will nicht das aus dem Namen bringen, google das mal kurz.
Also,
Burschenschaft Saxonia Tschernowitz?
Nee, nee, HDJ oder so.
Heimattreue Deutsche Jugend?
Guck mal kurz.
Heimattreue Deutsche Jugend.
Ja klar, HDJ sind noch so ein klar D, wie bei AfD das F. Also.
Du hast einen Kalbitz, der rausfliegt, weil der 2007 auf dem Lager,
nee 2009, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, 2007, 2009, gesehen wurde auf dem Lager der HDJ.
HDJ, Nachfolgeorganisation der Bund Heimattreue Jugend, die den Bundesführer hatte, wie heißt er?
Gernot Mürick. So, da wurde Kalbitz gesehen, ist rausgeflogen.
Und dann hast du einen Roland Hartwig, der auf dieses Treffen geht,
vom ehemaligen Bundesführer, von diesem Ding, wo die selbst der AfD angeblich zu rechts waren,
der dann sich, als der Kalbitz rausgeflogen ist, an Kalbitz' Seite gestellt
hat, und hat gesagt, das geht nicht, dass ihr ihn rausfliegen lasst.
Und daraufhin wurde sein Bundestagsmandat nicht verlängert, er wurde von der
AfD von der Liste genommen, weil er sich solidarisch gezeigt hat mit Kalbitz.
Hat also ein grundvölkliches Verständnis, würde ich mal behaupten.
Und tritt dort auf und sagt dort klipp und klar, ich bin die rechte Hand von,
also er sagt, ich bin der Berater und persönliche Referent von Dr.
Alice Weidel und wir als Vorstand.
Also er tritt dort auf als Vorstand der AfD. Und das ist dann rechtlich relevant,
weil dann hast du jemanden, der
sagt, ich bin hier als Vorstand der AfD-Bundespartei. Das ist die Linie.
In dem Augenblick wird es auch für ein Verbot relevant, weil da jemand ist,
der ganz öffentlich auftritt als.
Deswegen hat auch Weidel, mutmaße ich jetzt mal, am Ende sich entschieden,
der muss weg. Ich muss jetzt Konsequenzen ziehen.
Wir haben uns umgehört innerhalb der AfD und haben da verschiedene Quellen,
die gesagt haben, der ist sozusagen eine Art von inoffizieller Parteigenerhalter.
ist das? Geschäftsführer, nicht Geschäftsführer, Generalsekretär.
Und ich weiß, er soll wohl ziemlich faul sein und der macht die ganze Arbeit für die und so.
Und der war dort und hat gesagt, das, was ihr hier macht, finde ich ganz toll.
Das Buch von Martin Sellner ist so toll.
Das ist ein ganz toller Typ und so.
Und dieser Arne Friedrich Möhrig, seinen Vortrag leite ich jetzt ein und wir
wollen uns das angucken als Vorstand und auch Geld in die Hand nehmen und und das alles fördern.
Da hast du eine Linie, die wird dann relevant. Das ist eigentlich der Kern,
wo man sagen kann, aha, jetzt now we're talking.
Und du würdest ja schon, also wen könnte jetzt einen kurzen Ausflug machen?
Also natürlich macht nicht das Gesicht, das da vorne steht, also Alice Weidel
oder Tino Chrupalla oder auch Olaf Scholz oder auch Robert Habeck die Politik.
Die stehen ja da, die Die sagen am Ende, yo, in Ordnung, geh mal dahin oder
sonst was. Genauso wie der CEO von einem Unternehmen nicht die Arbeit macht.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen. Die stehen schon für Dinge gerade.
Die Denkarbeit machen sie vielleicht nicht.
Ich hätte jetzt eher ein produzierendes Unternehmen. Irgendwo stehen Leute.
Aber es ist schon so, dass eine durchschnittliche deutsche Bundestagsabgeordnete,
Die hat ja so viele Termine,
dass sie auf ihre Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen sich verlassen muss, um Dinge umzusetzen.
Und diese Mitarbeiterinnen haben natürlich mehr Zeit, um die Dinge ordentlich zu machen.
Die kriegen natürlich eine Vorgabe,
denen wird gesagt, geh mal in die Richtung, geh mal in die Richtung.
Aber so viele Fototermine wie eine Bundestagsabgeordnete oder eine Regierungsbeteiligte
oder auch eine Oppositionspolitikerin hat, gibt es dahinter die Mitarbeiter,
die die Arbeit wirklich machen.
Einfach ein kleines Beispiel, Film, den viele unserer Hörerinnen kennen,
Democracy im Rausch der Daten.
Da gibt es Jan Philipp Albrecht, das ist der Europaparlamentsabgeordnete,
der da für die Werte einsteht und nach draußen das kommuniziert und so weiter.
Und dann gibt es den Ralf Bendrath, der, naja, the legwork macht.
Der mit den Leuten redet, der Dinge an ihn heranträgt und sagt so sinngemäß,
jetzt haben wir noch die 20 Lobbyisten hier, was machen wir mit denen, wie machen wir das hier.
Die Gesetze schreibt ja, oder die Texte, die liest ja dann nicht am Ende der
JPA, der Jan-Philipp Albrecht selber, sondern das macht ja dann der Ralf Benrath.
Dafür haben die ja ihre Mitarbeiter. weiter.
Und wenn du jetzt der oder wenn man sich solche Politikserien anschaut,
wie hier, wie heißt das, diese Weiße Haus nicht die dystopische Weißhaus-Serie,
es gibt ja hier House of Cards und wie heißt das, das war ungefähr zehn Jahre vorher,
mit dem Präsidenten, den man mochte, der keinen umgebracht hat und so.
Welcher Präsident keinen umgebracht hat? Sorry.
Aber Jetzt direkt. Aber in beiden Serien ist eigentlich ganz klar,
der Chief of Staff, der Eigen Der eigentliche Mann mit der Macht.
An dem müssen die alle vorbei. Einfach allein schon, weil der den Kalender kontrolliert vom Präsidenten.
In der Konfrontation haben wir auch direkt Alice Weidel konfrontiert,
weil klar war, der arbeitet für die.
Und der ist ihre Rechte an.
Der liest die E-Mails. Das war völlig klar.
Und der sitzt da und lässt sich bei sowas erwischen ich meine das ist der Detail,
den jetzt Alice weil ihm zur Last legen muss also das ist ja wirklich unwahrscheinlich,
dass sie jetzt nicht wusste dass der genau da ist,
Und welche Position der da vertritt? War das am Wochenende oder war das unter der Woche?
Das war am Samstag, ja.
Ja gut, also kann man sich noch rausreden, aber der wird ja jetzt nicht.
Nee, aber das ist ja ganz zum Punkto Privattreffen. Also war ein privates Treffen.
Erstens sind da Funktionen. Zweitens, er redet ganz offen als ich hier, als wir als Vorstand.
Drittens, es wird mehrfach gesagt, an dieser Stelle, so wie wir hier sind,
das würden wir in der Öffentlichkeit nicht machen.
Drittens, bitte alles nur postalisch. Alles bitte geheim halten,
so ungefähr. Also das heißt, es war definitiv als ein Geheimtreffen gedacht.
Und viertens, guckt dir doch mal kurz an, was der Papen damals, wann war das? 1933.
Die haben sich ja getroffen im Privaten mit einem NSDAP-Mitglied,
der gesagt hat, wir wollen Hitler an die Macht holen.
Das war ein Privattreffen, wenn man so will.
Aber natürlich wird wird vieles in Privattreffen gemacht. Das war jetzt ja nur ein Privattreffen.
Wenn Olaf Scholz da irgendwie Cum-Ex vergisst, das war auch kein Privattreffen.
Also ja, war ein Privattreffen, natürlich.
Nee, aber viel diskutiert wird im Nachhinein, war es geheim oder was nicht geheim, war es privat.
Natürlich treffen nicht die ganze Zeit Nazis irgendwie und planen irgendwelche
Dinge, aber da waren Funktionen da.
Und diese Funktionäre haben als Funktionäre auch gehandelt. Das muss man schon sagen.
Das muss man schon sagen und ich finde
auch tatsächlich, du kannst ja auch irgendwann das nicht mehr trennen.
Also bei einem solchen, das ist ja kein 9-to-5-Job. Ich bin von morgens um 9
bis 17 Uhr bin ich der persönliche Referent von Alice Weidel,
am Wochenende, Freitag nach 6 macht jeder seins oder wie das sagt.
Wenn ich auch noch sage, ich bin der und wir als Vorstand werden.
Also das ist ja, ja, ja. Gut.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die AfD-Leute sich da groß rausgehen können.
Die drohen jetzt rum, aber nicht juristisch.
Also die haben alles, was wir bis jetzt gemacht haben, haben sie auf die eine
oder andere Art und Weise bestätigt.
Manche sagen, alles nicht wahr, alles Lügen. Die anderen sagen,
es ist ja ein vielstimmiger Chor, die AfD. AfD.
Und während die einen sagen, Remigration ist kein Geheimplan,
das ist ein Versprechen und die hier gerne und mürrig sagen,
ja, das habe ich schon gesagt mit diesem logistischer Vorbereitung und der nächste
sagt irgendwie, ja, okay, das habe ich gesagt, aber das nicht.
Die bestätigen ja bis jetzt alles, was wir gesagt haben. Das,
was sie sagen, sei nicht gesagt, dann sollen die Juristik dagegen vorgehen.
Wir haben bis jetzt noch keinen Brief bekommen. Der sagt, das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Außer, das stimmt schon, Mario Müller, der,
schon für Gewalt verurteilt, also der wurde verurteilt für eine Schlägerei,
wo der selber, ich weiß nicht mehr genau was, aber der hatte irgendwas,
war auf jeden Fall Schlägereien dabei gegen Zivikops und der arbeitet im Bundestag,
Und der hat gesagt, nee, diese Dokumentation Links-X-Mistus-Töter-Kalane,
der ist gar nicht von mir.
Aber würde nicht stimmen, das
hat er aber dort tatsächlich vor der ganzen Meute gesagt, er wäre der...
Das ist der, der sich mit den Gewaltaktionen... Genau.
Der ist der absolute Antifa-Jäger von vorn bis hinten.
Das war ganz interessant, weil der dort gesagt hat, mein Name ist Mario Müller,
ich bin gewaltbereiter Neonazi, wenn man den Linken glaubt, also die ganzen
Denunzianten nennen mich so, aber wenn man das glauben will,
dann muss man auch glauben, dass Maaßen Verschwörungstheoretiker ist.
Das ist ja wirklich.
Das ist echte Personalie. Also ich meine, findet man in der Wikipedia unter
Mario Müller, Klammer auf, Neonazi.
Den Beruf musst du erstmal verdienen.
Gut, Mario Müller ist jetzt, das ist natürlich zur Begriffsklärung,
aber das ist halt das, was er ist.
88 in Bremen geboren, Mitglied der jungen Nationaldemokraten, Identitären Bewegung,
aktive Teilnahme an Treffen von Rechtsextremen in Potsdam 2023,
okay, das ist jetzt da sind wir dann auch schon so und er, der ist wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter des,
Bundestagsabgeordneten Jan Wenzel-Schmidt und jetzt wie findest, also,
wie kriegst du denn also erstmal glaube ich hat er jetzt gar keine akademische
Karriere so, wo man sagen würde, den kannst du als wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter
einstellen eher so ein bisschen Straßenabitur.
Aber Guck mal ganz kurz, ein Tattoo hat er sich im Zusammenhang mit der Begegnung
ins Bein stechen ließ, zitiert ein Motto des Nazi-Dichters Hans Baumann,
Rebellen haben Tod und Teufel zum Gesellen. Also so ein Typ ist das.
Aber wie kommt denn, also Redakteur des rechtsextremen Magazins Kompakt, das kann also...
Der ist jetzt nicht durch Zufall Mitarbeiter eines Bundestagsabgeordneten und
ich glaube genau davon hat er auch da gesprochen bei diesem Treffen,
wenn ich das im Theaterstück richtig gesehen habe.
Der hat einiges erzählt, der hat, naja Theaterstück ist Theaterstück,
das wollen wir mal in Klammern halten, weil da...
Dann nehmen wir den Artikel, den Korrektiv da oben.
Genau, also was der dort gesagt hat, ist, dass er, und das sind zwei Punkte,
die ich wichtig finde und da würde ich noch einen Unterpunkt machen.
Zum einen, er hat dieses Dokumentation-Links-Istimismus-Twitter-Account,
zusammen mit Dorian Schubert übrigens. Durian Schubert, auch ein bekannter Neonazi.
Da haben wir interne Chats bekommen, wo der diesen Typen, der einen Bombenanschlag
in Freiburg auf ein autonomes Zentrum geplant hat und den grüßt er so mit 88.
Also es ist so, das ist Dorian Schubert, mit dem zusammen behauptet er,
muss ich dazu sagen, würde er dieses Twitter-Account Dokumentation Legitimismus machen.
Wenn ihr euch das heute anguckt, ist es irgendwie privat geworden,
haben sie jetzt abgeschaltet. Bis dahin hast du da gefunden,
immer wieder die Markierung von verschiedenen Menschen.
Also auch Journalistinnen, Journalisten, teilweise der Welt,
die dazu gegen Nazis recherchiert haben, wurden dort als linksradikale U-Boote und so weiter markiert.
und der hat, also sagt, guck mal, das machen wir,
ich will aber nicht, dass das öffentlich bekannt wird, also hier aber geile
Arbeit, die ich mache und dann hat er gesagt, übrigens,
als der Typ von Lina E, da muss man jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen ausholen,
Lina E ist verurteilt worden, das geht jetzt in Revision.
Als linksradikale oder als für linksextreme Gewalt verurteilt worden, In erster Instanz.
Da geht es jetzt zur nächsten Instanz.
Und die haben da in Konnewitz angeblich irgendwelche Leute verprügelt und so. Konnewitz.
Ein Stadtteil von Leipzig. Genau.
Und da hat einer aus der Gruppe rund um Lina E.
ist dann nach Polen. Ich sag mal, ich weiß nicht, wie kontensual das war.
Remigriert.
Remigriert, genau. Ne, der kommt nicht nach Polen. Der ist nach Polen migriert.
Und der war, soweit ich das verstanden habe,
ich muss gestehen, ich bin da nicht so super tief drin, aber der hat wohl eine
Vergewaltigung, wurde der von den Leuten aus der eigenen Gruppe verurteilt,
aber nicht vor Gericht, aber es war sozusagen, der sollte K.U.
Tropfen oder was genutzt haben, also ziemlich üble Sache und die gehen natürlich
nicht zur Polizei, die machen dann Online-Ding.
Also alles in Lammertal verfangen, der Typ haut ab, geht nach Polen,
arbeitet dort als Kindergärtner,
will sich ein neues Leben aufbauen. Und dann sagt dieser Mario Möhrig und das
habe ich rausgefunden, das haben wir rausgefunden, sagt er.
Und wir haben das dann den Medien gegeben, den polnischen Medien,
die haben es veröffentlicht und dann sind,
Fußballfans.
Erlebnisorientierte Fußballfans.
Haben ihn sportlich handfest konfrontiert. Das heißt, du hast einen Typen,
der sitzt im Bundestag und der brüstet sich damit, dass der Und dann ist er
zum Kronzeugen geworden im Fall Dinae.
Das heißt, er ist involviert, zumindest, damit brüstet er sich,
jemanden zu jagen, der hinterher so eingeschüchtert wird, dass er als Kronzeuge
in einem Fall vor Gericht in Deutschland aussagt.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Dass das alles getrennt wird. Das darf nicht zusammenliegen.
Dann sagt der, und da will ich auch noch mehr Geld für haben,
und zwar von allen möglichen Leuten.
Das heißt, der möchte von der Partei Geld haben, um das auszubauen, diese Struktur.
Da würde ich denken, der will eigentlich, denkt der, ist mein Eindruck zumindest,
deswegen habe ich es im Theaterstück auch so beschrieben, der denkt an Gestapo.
Also das ist sozusagen, die haben immer wieder in Vorbildern der Gestapo oder
der Nazis gedacht, die haben ihren Hitler einfach gut gelesen.
Ja, ähm, tut mir leid.
Das war ein ziemlich harter Tobak.
Ja.
Ist harter Tobak.
Aber das sind sozusagen, jetzt müssen wir kurz mal die Klammer wieder schließen,
also wir sind jetzt bei Mario Müller gestartet,
so, neben Martin Sellner und noch einem weiteren von dieser identitären Bewegung,
dessen Name jetzt vielleicht nicht so relevant ist, so, das war so.
Naja, ich hab Vermutung, wer das ist, aber wir können das auf den Fotos nicht eindeutig.
Okay, also man weiß es nicht so genau. Auf jeden Fall, das war so ein bisschen
die Neonazi-Fraktion in dieser Gruppe.
Aber das ist ja eine Nummer für sich, dass dieser, also einfach nur,
was der Typ da erzählt hat oder was man jetzt über den herausgefunden hat,
das ist ja schon eine Nummer für sich, die ein Wahnsinn ist.
Das ist ein bezahlter Mitarbeiter eines Bundeshausabgeordneten.
Genau. Ich glaube, der hat keinen Hausausweis.
Der aufgrund seiner Vergangenheit darf denn nicht in den Bundeshaus.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Also irgendwie so, der hat keinen Hausausweis. Ich glaube, das stand sogar in
eurem Artikel, dass der auch, also auch, wenn du keinen Hausausweis hast,
kannst du ja trotzdem im Bundestag, aber der darf da trotzdem nicht rein.
Ja, und du hast ja Zugang trotzdem zu Akten. Also du kannst ja,
wenn es Storcher wäre, der hat ja, das ist ein Finanzausschuss,
Familienausschuss, das sind ja alles Sachen, die sind, da hat er einen Zugang zu.
Und.
Ich lese hier übrigens gerade, dass Bundesministerium des Inneren jetzt prüft,
ob man vielleicht den Herrn Sellner mal nicht mehr nach Deutschland lässt.
Der hat ja schon für USA und UK hat der schon so ein Verbot.
Deutschland prüft Grenzschließung für Neonazi-Sellner.
Das ist geil, oder? Ja.
Tja.
Ich weiß ja gar nicht, was hätte
ein Hitler gemacht, wenn er nicht nach Deutschland hätte gehen können?
Ich will die Vergleiche jetzt nicht aufmachen, das geht nicht. Das wird...
Sorry, also ich meine die Ernst, es ist wirklich kein Vergleich.
Es ist kein, also genau, jeder Vergleich in der Richtung ist natürlich irgendwie
falsch, kann aber, wenn man jetzt nicht aufpasst, irgendwann in 10, 15 Jahren doch passen.
Und das ist ja der der, der, also der Aspekt, um den es hier geht,
dass es irgendwie schon zu weit getrieben wurde. Also ich finde, Ja.
Also ich finde allein diese Story mit diesem Mario Müller schon hart genug. Ja.
Klar. Also es wird ja bei AfD-Verbot immer diskutiert, juristisch,
ja gut, aber die haben ja noch keinen Schläger-Trupp in den Straßen wie die Gestapo damals.
Wollen wir da noch drauf warten? So.
Und ich meine, ich habe mich auch gefragt, also weil, wie ich Holocaust vergleiche,
es gibt einfach keinen historischen Moment wie den Holocaust. Das ist singulär.
Das muss man sehr klar sagen.
Wir haben aber, alle sind ausgestattet mit einem Gehirn, was assoziativ arbeitet.
Und da glaube ich, das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum wir diese Geschichte so eingeschlagen ist.
Denn du hast zwei Gruppen in Deutschland, wenn ich jetzt mal ganz platt sein darf.
Das eine sind die Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund und das andere sind die
Menschen mit Nazi-Hintergrund.
Und die Menschen mit Nazi-Hintergrund haben halt gemerkt, Scheiße,
das erinnert mich an irgendwas aus meiner Familie.
Und jetzt habe ich die Möglichkeit zu zeigen, was ich gemacht hätte,
wenn ich an der Stelle meiner Großeltern wäre.
Die anderen sagen, Scheiße, die wollen mich aus dem Land schieben.
Das heißt, alle, die das gelesen haben, hatten irgendwie eine Form von direkter
Betroffenheit und einen Bezug zu dem Text.
Das war mir vorher nicht so klar, aber das ist eine, es gibt viele Erklärungen,
wie kam das dazu, dass diese Information, diese Nachricht, denn das war es am
Ende, es war eine Nachricht, mehr nicht,
so solche Wellen geschlagen hat.
Das hat einfach mit allen direkt was zu tun, ob du es willst oder nicht.
Da hast du eben so einen Lindemann, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Video gesehen
habt, das war Wahnsinn, Lindemann in der Tagesschau oder so,
wo die das Kamera haben laufen lassen und der fünfmal wiederholt hat.
Wer, welcher? Ach, dieser Lindemann, der Lottogewinner oder wer? Nee.
CDU, CDU, was ist der?
Der Generalsekretär von der CDU ist aber Lindemann.
Lindemann, Lindemann, nee, genau, nicht der Rammstein, denke ich.
Ja, ich fand diese Geschichte von Lindemann, wie er da sich geäußert hat zu
den zwei Werte-Unions-Leuten, die da waren, die fand ich einfach so besonders,
weil du gesehen hast, wie ein CDUler versucht,
das irgendwie einzufangen und 50 Mal, naja, nicht 50 Mal, aber ein paar Mal
wiederholt die ausgebildet gelernten Sätze, dass er unheimlich erschrocken war.
da merkst du so uh, das hab ich ja nicht kommen sehen, das wäre ich ja aus meinem Lager,
da zerbreche ich mir den ganzen Tag den Kopf darüber, plötzlich ist er aufgewacht und das war wie so,
als, ich mein sorry aber du hast die Werteunion nicht seit gestern da und die
machen ja nichts anderes als die Brandmauer abzubauen und der war plötzlich
ganz erschrocken, ganz erschrocken und das zeigt Aber willst du sagen.
Du glaubst ihm das nicht?
Pff, guck mir das Video mal an. Verlinkt ihr bestimmt in den Shownotes.
Da wiederholt er seinen Satz, auswendig gelernt, immer wieder, wie entzürnt der war.
Das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues, dass die CDU einen harten rechten Rand hat.
Ich meine, es gab schon so viele, die abgewandert sind. Wie hieß noch die Trulla,
die jetzt diese AfD-Stiftung anführt?
Oh, ja stimmt.
Erika Steinbach.
Genau.
Okay, die haben sich auch reingetreten.
In gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja auch ein Feature von der CDU gewesen,
weil sie ja im Prinzip diese ganzen rechten Leute irgendwie eingebunden und
davon abgehalten hat, sowas wie eine AfD zu gründen.
Und das war ja eigentlich auch schon immer die Politik der CDU gewesen.
Nix darf rechts von uns.
Genau.
Das ist natürlich auch erstmal eine richtige Vorgabe.
Ich meine, die Leute gibt es ja. Das ist insofern eine Funktion,
die die CDU so nicht mehr leistet.
Und was jetzt gerade passiert mit der Spiegelrecherche, die daraufhin rauskam
von dem ehemaligen Finanzsenator in Berlin, der auch sowas organisiert hat, solche Treffen und so.
Da merkst du, ach du Scheiße, wir haben jetzt doch ein bisschen zu viel geflirtet
auf dem rechten Rand und du hast jetzt von den Leuten,
die sich damit lange auseinandersetzen, die sagen, ja gut, das wussten wir alles
schon, das ist jetzt nichts Neues, bis hin zu denen, die sagen,
huch, da sind wir jetzt ganz überrascht, hast jetzt alle dabei,
die sagen, das geht nicht.
Und das ist eine neue Qualität. Das ist schon beachtenswert.
Das ist der Peter Kurt, der auch irgendwie Privattreffen mit Selna und so weiter veranstaltet hat.
Wen von den Personen müssen wir denn jetzt auch nochmal erwähnen,
um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wer war.
Was wir auch noch nicht gesagt haben, ist so, die Zahl von Leuten.
Also wie viele Leute haben denn eigentlich tatsächlich daran teilgenommen?
Wie genau weiß man das? Wisst ihr das?
Da muss ich auch ein bisschen meine Quellen schützen. So genau zwischen 20 und
30. Alle können wir nicht nennen.
Du hast auf jeden Fall Alexander von Bismarck dabei.
Das ist dieser verstrahlte, übrigens kein direkter Nachfahre.
Da haben wir noch Post von der Familie von Bismarck bekommen.
Der gute Name.
Döbelin und was, andere Linie und so. Der ist bekannt geworden,
weil er Rosen verteilt hat vom Panzer hier von Ennolenze, den der Abge...
Ennolenze hat einen russischen Panzer unter den Linden hingestellt vor die russische
Botschaft Der war nicht mehr Der war glaube ich kaputt, der Panzer Und der hat
dann eine Rose vor dem Panzer gelegt,
um den russischen Soldaten zu gedenken, oder was?
Ja, genau Der ist auch wirklich Aber der ist wirklich ziemlich verstromert.
Alexander von Bismarck.
Ich wollte eigentlich in der Recherche immer nur irgendeinen Bismarck schreiben,
weil der so verstrahlt ist.
Aber auch Mitglied der CDU Auch Ist er das?
Ist er Mitglied der CDU? Da hätten wir einen vierten CDU Wir hatten ja nämlich auch Ulrich Vosgerau,
Also Von der CDU hat es auf jeden Fall zwei aus der Werteunion,
Schneider Und Baum Die sind mittlerweile, waren auch im Foto Jetzt ist der von
der Maaßenpartei Mit drin Dann hattest du den Ulrich Vosgerau,
der ist der Anwalt der die AfD vertritt und die vom Verfassungsgericht und die Delirium Stiftung,
dann hast du Henning Pless das ist so ein Typ der mit so Darm Zeugs bei Instagram
bekannt wurde Instagram Profil ist seitdem auch gesperrt.
Darm Zeugs?
Ja irgendwie wie man besser essen kann und wie deine Kacke ist und so Reinigung und so.
Rechtsextremer Heilpraktiker und Esoteriker habt ihr dazu geschrieben.
Ja.
Das ist ja auch...
Da gibt es auch... Ja.
Dazu empfehle ich den Film Mondverschwörung. Da ist das alles sehr schön,
schon in seiner prototypischen Zusammenhängung sehr schön zusammengefasst.
Dann hast du noch einen Blut- und Boden-Nazi und IT-Unternehmer,
so stand der bei uns im Text, kann man ja auch nennen, das ist Christoph Hofer.
Der ist in der Netzpolitik.org-Artikel. Genau.
Das muss ich auch mal sagen, also was seitdem passiert ist, wir sind ja jetzt
kein Riesenteam bei Korrektiv.
Wir haben sehr viele Informationen und wir können die alle nicht gleichzeitig verarbeiten.
Das heißt, das machen wir, das machen wir nicht, das machen wir, das machen wir nicht.
Seitdem das Ding raus ist.
Ich stehe meine Tage nur noch daraus, wir sind nämlich halt nicht wie andere
Medienhäuser, sind wir gemeinnützig, das heißt, das Zeug muss raus.
Wir können halt nicht alles ordentlich journalistisch verarbeiten,
also bin ich nur dabei, anderen guten, fitten Journalistinnen und Journalisten
die Informationen weiterzugeben.
Zu sagen, okay, der, das, das ist der Hintergrund, guck mal,
von dem habe ich noch ein Foto, das habe ich noch Dings, guck mal,
auf dem Blog habe ich das über den gefunden und so.
Und so kam auch Markus Reuter und sein Kollege und denen habe ich dann ein paar
Informationen gegeben, das eingeordnet. Ich habe Fotos gefunden,
wie der einen Preis gewonnen hat in Thüringen.
Und das wurde alles dann veröffentlicht. Wunderbar unter dem Titel Braune IT und rechte Influencer.
Da haben die eben geguckt, wer war denn dieser Blut und Boden Nazi?
Und der hat da eben diese TEDx Sex Awards,
2001 Thüringens Aber der hat die Sex Awards gewonnen. Nee.
Das ist doch irgendwie Gründer im Gründerpreis. Ja.
Also genau. Und seitdem fließen da auch wieder ganz viele Hinweise,
mit wem der alles zusammenarbeitet.
Genau, das ist dieser Hofer. Wen hat man?
Da hat man einen Neurochirurgen, der ist heute auch bei… Da haben wir den Neuroschirurgen,
das war auch ein Typ, der einfach im Publikum saß und,
der hat eine Neuroschirurgie gehabt, der ist ja jetzt rausgeflogen.
Also ist heute bei Dossier rausgekommen, da hatte ich journalistischen Kollegen
vom Standard und vom Dossier, Dossier ist sowas ähnliches wie Korrektiv in Österreich,
dem ist man weiter ausrecherchiert.
Es ist wirklich toll, wie alle dabei sind, jetzt.
Zum Anlass zu nehmen, um weiter zu gucken, was gibt es denn dann noch für Hinweise.
Da gab es natürlich die Angestellten, die haben damit nichts zu tun.
die haben einfach gearbeitet und dann hast du die die Gastgeber natürlich,
die Leute, denen das Hotel gehört.
Da hast du die Huss, die ist da hat die Zeit auch einen Artikel über die veröffentlicht.
Mathilda Martina Huss, ich glaube die hat zwei Vornamen und,
da hat Christian Fuchs einen langen Artikel über die veröffentlicht vor kurzem
und ihr Mann Wilhelm Wildering, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht,
der in der CDU Potsdam ist.
Damit hast du den Vosgerau CDU, Werteunion 2 CDU, Wildering CDU. Das sind schon mal vier.
Und du hast gesagt, der Alexander von Bismarck ist auch CDU.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Wenn man den googelt, dann findet man irgendwie
einen Link auf Wikipedia, wo das steht, aber wenn man da drauf geht,
steht da die Seite gibt es nicht. Also da müssen wir ganz nur genehmigte Informationen.
Der ist so ein bisschen irre, also den würde ich auch aus allem ein bisschen rausnehmen.
Irrelevant meinst du?
Irrelevant, ja. Viel Geld. Der wurde leider nicht enteignet von den nach dem
Krieg. Also das haben sie verpasst.
Die Monarchie in Deutschland im Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern sind wir viel zu milde mit umgegangen.
Also diese Martina Huss, die ist die, du hast es gesagt, von dem Hotel,
von dem Treffen, von dem Ort.
Ja.
Okay, also es ist nicht so, dass die Location nicht wusste, wen sie dort.
Nee.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Das behaupten die jetzt. Also die sagen, die fragen nicht, worüber geredet wird.
Die waren aber dabei, die saßen mit im Raum, die haben das mit organisiert.
Und die, ja, also die können dich da auch nicht rausreden. Das ist leider so.
So eine Gruppe haben wir jetzt noch nicht erwähnt, die müssen wir jetzt aber
dann doch nochmal erwähnen, weil das ist auch so ein Laden, der mich irgendwie
schon immer genervt hat.
Martin Sellner postet ja gerade ihr TikTok-Video, das hat die alle unter einer Decke stecken.
Und der Verein Deutsche Sprache hat ja durchaus in den letzten Folgen Logbuch-Netzmusik
eine Rolle gespielt, weil die mir ja geile E-Mails geschrieben haben oder CC
waren in geilen E-Mails.
Wirklich? Ja.
Versehentlich bei Markus Lanz ist mir geil, der Begriff geil.
Wirklich, hast du das gesagt? Welches Wort? Das Wort geil.
Hab ich im Fernsehen gesagt?
Nein. Doch. Nein.
Ja doch.
Nein.
So ist er. Einfach so.
Dann kamen E-Mails und Briefe im Chaos Computer Club an und wurde sich dann
darüber erkundigt, ob ich einen Samenabgang gehabt hätte und so weiter.
Und da war dann der Fall, eine deutsche Sprache.
CC. So, dann will ich vielleicht kurz was vorweg schieben. Ich habe hier ein
Buch in meinen Händen geschrieben.
Herausgeber Gernot Möhrig. Das heißt Deutschlands junge Zukunft.
Jugendliche Antworten auf Fragen der Zeit.
Erschienen beim Arndt Verlag mit DT. Das kriegt man in Antiquar noch im Internet, wenn man das will.
Von unserem Möhrig Zahnarzt aus Düsseldorf.
Der das alles organisiert hat. Und das ist veröffentlicht worden 1981.
Wurde vor mir veröffentlicht. Vor dir. Da ist alles mögliche an völkischem Zeugs
drin. Also wie mit Ausländern überhaupt.
Und der ist auch gegen Windräder übrigens. Und da ist ein Kapitel,
das nehme ich jetzt raus. Also es gibt wirklich viele eklige, dreckige Kapitel.
Aber du willst jetzt nicht das ganze Kapitel vorlesen. Aber dieses eine,
das fand ich schon interessant.
Weil er schon damals, 1981, sich über die deutsche Sprache...
Da war er selber noch jung.
Da war er selber noch jung. Er ist heute 69 Jahre alt, zumindest soweit ich weiß.
Und 81 schreibt er, good morning Leute, mit dieser Glosse stellt eine Schülerin
die Verslängung der deutschen Sprache bloß. Aber sie sucht nach Ursachen und Lösungen.
Und dann geht es so. Good morning, Leute.
Seid ihr auch up to date gewesen und habt zum Breakfast Popcorn gefuttert,
wie es die Slogans des Television befohlen haben? Okay.
Und immer diese englischen Worte sind immer kursiv, ja? Okay,
dann schnell hinein in den Swimmingpool, wie es die Chemiklier der High Society
geht. Und so geht es die ganze Zeit weiter.
Du merkst.
Der ist so erbost darüber, dass es Worte gibt, die nicht urdeutsch sind.
Und das ist ein ganzes Kapitel über ihr Business Speech Establishment Jet Set im Non-Stop-Flug.
Muss man jetzt mal so sagen, hat er schon einiges vorweggenommen,
wie wir heute sprechen. Also der war da an was dran.
Der hat einen ganz heißen Spruch gehabt.
Aber da merkst du, denen geht es ja ja wirklich um diese Kultur,
diese also, dass wir wirklich Wie ist das? Die Nazis haben ja auch die Pistole.
Weißt du das? Die Pistole durfte nicht Pistole genannt werden.
Sondern?
Meuchelpuffer.
Was?
Bitte?
Das hab ich ja noch nie gehört.
Guck dir mal den Meuchelpuffer an. Also hab ich mal gehört. Ich weiß nicht genau,
wie streng das dann genommen wurde.
Flusswaffe mit kurzen Lauf, die aus einer...
Das ist der Meuchelpuffer.
Deutscher Schreiber ist wirklich der Wikipedia-Artikel dazu.
Erfolglos blieben dagegen Wortschöpfungen wie Zeugemutter für Natur,
Entgliederer für Anatom, Jungpfannzwinger für Nonnenkloster und Meuchelpuffer.
Das ist alles, also das und das. Die wollen auch nicht Webseite sagen,
sondern die sagen halt digitaler Schaukasten.
Ja, die sind ja auch im Weltnetz und so.
Also diese Idee von der deutschen Sprache, dass die bloß nicht gendern darf
und jetzt wird es ja ernst,
da merkst du, das ist ein Eintrittstor in die bürgerliche Welt,
mit der man fischen kann für Menschen und die aufs rechte Lager bringen kann.
Das heißt, warum reden so viele Leute über Gendern? Weil das eben ein Vehikel ist.
Und alle Leute, die sich jetzt echauffieren und sagen, hör mal auf zu gendern,
sie darf es nicht sagen, vergesst nicht, dass ihr da Teil seid einer rechtsradikalen
Ideologie, die deutsche Sprache irgendwie verteidigen will.
Das ist gezielt. Und diese Silke Schröder hat als Vorsitzende des ehemals,
glaube ich, die ist auch rausgeflogen, Sloterdijk ist da auch direkt ausgetreten,
die Halle vorne war da glaube ich auch drin. Ich weiß nicht.
Ob der ausgetreten ist, aber der ist ja auch ein bisschen weggetreten inzwischen.
Also das ist so dieses Sprachspiel, meinetwegen kannst du mich nennen,
wie du willst, kannst du auch mit, also was soll das denn?
Also ich hätte keinen Beleg für deine Behauptung, dass Meuchelpuffer was mit den Nazis zu tun hat.
Nein.
Natürlich. Deutscher Sprachpurismus. Bestrebungen deutscher Sprache.
19. Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts. Ah.
Okay.
Kein direkter Nazi-Bezug.
Sagen wir mal so, ein paar Nazis werden Meuchelpuffer gesagt haben.
Als sie in Stalingrad verloren haben.
Meuchelpuffer ist auch ein bisschen bescheuert. Wie kommen wir jetzt einen Sendungstitel
hin ohne Meuchelpuffer?
Das ist ja scheiße. Danke.
John. Nee.
Aber wenn ich das verstehe, ist das eher so ein spöttischer Begriff.
Der war schon so gemeint, wie er jetzt auch klingt.
Ja, okay.
Man kann jetzt den Nazis auch nicht alles angreifen.
Ja, da mögen wir entschuldigen.
Die wollen 25 Prozent der Bevölkerung sich entledigen. Die wollen uns alle umbringen
und die hassen uns und wollen nicht, dass wir ein schönes Leben haben und in
Zukunft wollen sie uns auch rauben.
Aber Meuchelpuffer, das haben sie nicht gemacht.
Haben sie nicht verbrochen. Und ich möchte mich an der Stelle entschuldigen.
Ich habe an der Stelle nicht ordentlich recherchiert.
Aber gut, dass wir das noch mal...
Wir sind Checker.
Ja.
Wir haben hier den Logbuch Netzpolitik,
korrektiv. So sieht es nicht aus.
Das ist die wahre heiße Zeit. Hier gibt es gleich einen Pool.
Was?
Im Swimmingpool?
Also, die Vereine...
Wie heißt der Verein?
Verein Deutsche Sprache. Ja. Ich meine, Leute, wirklich, die gehen einem doch
schon lange auf den Sack.
Immer diese dummen Kommentare. Keinerlei.
Das ist schon geil.
In diesem Laden drückt sich ja so ein Mangel an Anpassungsfähigkeit aus.
Das ist ja sozusagen die fleischgefordene Verharrung.
Nichts darf sich ändern, nichts darf irgendwie sein und vor allem auch so dieses ähm,
Dieser fehlgeleitete Glaube, es gäbe so eine urdeutsche Geschichte und die deutsche
Sprache wäre irgendwann mal so aus dem Himmel herab zu uns gegeben worden und
genau so müsste es für immer sein, ist natürlich totaler Unsinn.
Jeder, der sich auch nur ein bisschen mit Sprache beschäftigt,
gibt immer Einflüsse von überall. Es.
Ist kein Zufall, dass ausgerechnet Silke Schröder nicht nur für den Deutschlandkurier
arbeitet, sondern dass auch die Person ist, die gefragt ist.
Martin Sellner, was machen wir denn mit den Leuten, die einen deutschen Pass haben?
Also als der seinen Vortrag gehalten hat.
Die war so richtig mit, das war die, die das gefragt hatte.
Ja, aber das ist doch ein Problem, was machen wir mit denen,
das ist doch ein Ding der Möglichkeit, was machen wir da?
Ja, kein Problem, das ist in der Tat das Schwierigste mit dem deutschen Pass,
das müssen wir irgendwie machen und so. Da werden die alle sagen,
was die nicht gesagt haben, aber das haben sie gesagt.
Was ich, vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zu dieser Idee des Sprachpurismus.
Also das ist nicht nur in Deutschland so, dass es das gibt.
Also in Frankreich sehr stark. Die haben ja, also in Frankreich haben die tatsächlich
irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch so ist, aber die haben Regelungen,
dass ausreichend französische Musik im Radio kommt, gehabt.
Die haben den Computer-Ordinateur genannt.
Minitel, weißt du, Minitel.
Die haben sehr darauf geachtet, dass sie die französische Kultur bewahren.
Und gegen so, und jetzt...
Da gibt es natürlich zwei Überlegungen zu. Natürlich ist es eine,
wenn du, sag ich mal, auf so eine nationale Identität Wert legst,
da musst du natürlich aufpassen, dass du eine eigene Kommunikation behältst.
Natürlich ist es für dich, wenn du auf nationale Identität Wert legst,
nicht in deinem Interesse, dass die Leute massenhaft andere Sprachen sprechen,
dass die Leute viele Lehnswörter aus anderen Sprachen haben,
weil das verwässert deinen Nationsbegriff. Ja.
Gleichzeitig, um jetzt noch einen weiterzugehen, also in Richtung 1984,
Newspeak und so weiter, ist es auch natürlich eine, wenn du sagst,
du willst möglichst die Gedanken der Leute kontrollieren oder einen Einfluss
darauf nehmen, wie sie denken,
dann ist die kleinste Einheit das Wort.
Ja.
Und insofern sind solche Bestrebungen nicht nur bescheuert, sondern die betten.
Sich ein in eine Nationsstrategie.
Natürlich nennen sie das Kultur, aber gerade Frankreich als Beispiel,
ich weiß nicht, ob die das heute noch machen, aber das war früher ein großes
Thema, dass sie damit ein Nationsgefühl bewahren.
indem sie diese fremden Wörter, die sind halt nicht von hier,
ja, und die wollen wir dann nicht benutzen, indem wir unsere eigenen Wörter...
Aber lass mal ein paar Schritte zurückgehen, weil ich würde das schon unterscheiden.
Also ob du sagst Poinier d'amour, ja, das ist ja in Deutschland heißt das Poinier
d'amour, es laufendelt auf Englisch, das ist in Deutschland ist das der Rettungsring.
Also Deutsche können das alles ja nicht. Wunderschön behalten wir Poinier d'amour, ja, das ist so.
Aber Aber was die in Frankreich auch machen, ist zu sagen, mindestens so und
so viele Franzosen müssen im Radio laufen.
Das ist aber erstmal eine ökonomische Stärkung der Kultur. Finde ich erstmal
interessant. Kann man machen.
Franzosen oder auf Französisch? Ist es auf Französisch?
Also Kanadier können auch. Ich meine schon.
Aber ich bin da kein Experte drin.
Okay, ja, auf keinen Fall. So, und dann, das andere ist, finde ich auch,
dass man, also ich finde, man muss schon aufpassen, wie sehr kann eine Sprache
sich weiterentwickeln und meine Ex-Freundin meinte immer, ich bereichere ja
die deutsche Sprache und das Entscheidende ist doch, dass man,
sie ist Spanierin, dass man sich versteht, ja, darum geht es ja,
dass man irgendwie kommunizieren kann,
dass Kultur sich wabert miteinander.
Und ich bin da ja voll dabei. Ich habe nur gerade extra gesagt,
wenn du darauf wertlegst, dass du irgendwie ein Nationsgefühl bewahren willst,
dann ist Sprache dein initialer Vektor. Also da musst du drauf achten.
Die Nazis haben nicht gesagt, wir machen hier unsere Reden in drei Sprachen,
damit wir alle verstehen.
Also die Sprache ist ja schon ein Schlüssel, um die Kultur zu verstehen.
Also wenn du verstehen willst, warum Deutsche so stock im Arsch präzise sind,
dann ist es, weil die so Kettenwörter machen können und vom Fabrikantenhut Besitzerstock
reden können und du denkst dir, was, Fabrikantenhut Besitzerstock, irgendwie,
hä, das geht jetzt nicht ganz, aber Fabrikantenbesitzerstock,
das geht schon und diese Kettenwörter sind halt so präzise in einem Wort,
das sind die Deutschen mit ihrer Präzision.
Und dann hast du halt, andere sind viel poetischer, deswegen sind die auch viel
offener in ihrem Geiste.
Okay, lassen Sie sich hier in so eine linguistische, ich würde ehrlich gesagt
sagen, dass die englische Sprache absolut überlegen ist durch ehrlich gesagt
präzisere Möglichkeiten des Ausdrucks, aber,
okay, da verlassen wir glaube ich alle unser Terrain.
Absolut komplett.
Da wäre ich auch ganz anderer Meinung.
Lass den Tim jetzt nochmal kurz über den Verein Deutsche Sprache runten.
Wallah, wir wir verlassen unser Terrain, oder?
Wallah, wir finden die Verein Deutsche Sprache awesome.
Naja, also im Prinzip haben wir ja alles dazu gesagt.
Du hast ja vorhin so eine These aufgestellt, warum jetzt das alles,
und vielleicht kommen wir jetzt auch einfach mal zu den Reaktionen,
die das alles ausgelöst hat.
Du hast ja gesagt, du siehst halt unter anderem diesen Aspekt,
so Leute mit ihrem Nazi-Hintergrund, also sozusagen der deutschen Abstammung
oder eben die Migration, alle sind irgendwie betroffen.
Man muss ja auch sagen, irgendwie 80 Prozent der Deutschen waren im Widerstand,
also waren nicht alle Nazis.
Mein Vater war bei der Marine im Widerstand.
Mein Opa. Gut.
Also das war jetzt deine These. Ich wollte nur sagen, wie ich das so empfunden
habe, weil als ich so auf diese Demo gegangen bin am Sonntag,
das Lustige war, ich bin hier in Prenzlauer Berg irgendwie gestartet,
ein paar Kilometer bis dahin und da waren schon unheimlich viele Leute zu Fuß unterwegs,
ganz offensichtlich auf dem Weg zu dieser Dieser Demo.
Also man merkte, umso näher man da rankommt, umso mehr Leute hat man gesehen.
Aber es war jetzt gar nicht mehr nur die Zahl, sondern eben auch was für Leute da waren.
Und man merkte einfach so eine Besorgnis. Und ich glaube, dass sehr viel bei
dieser Meldung auch konkret mit dieser bunten
oder gar nicht mal so bunten Zusammensetzung dieser Runde zu tun hat.
Weil es halt nicht nur die Neonazis haben sich getroffen und haben darüber gesprochen,
alle abzudeportieren oder auch nur die AfD,
sondern dass es so ein vergleichsweise breites Bündnis ist, was in alles reingeht.
in die Wirtschaft, weniger bekannte Personen und Gruppen,
dass sich wirklich nachhaltig so dieses Bild einer echten Verschwörung auch dargestellt hat.
Ist ein juristischer Begriff, darf es nicht nutzen. Verschwörung löschen wir
hier sofort. Wirklich. Wirklich.
Ich würde dem auch widersprechen, Tim, weil also ist es.
Menschen von ähnlichen politischen Interessen bilden Netzwerke.
Und die treffen sich auch, also ist das jetzt geheim?
Ja, ich meine hier wurden dokumentiert Maßnahmen ergriffen, um den Kreis klein
zu halten. Ja, wurde gesagt, komm, wir wollen mal unter uns reden.
Aber um das jetzt auch mal ein bisschen so zu normalisieren,
ich finde das schon auch in nicht-verschwörerischen Treffen völlig üblich,
zum Beispiel sowas zu sagen, wir machen mal Chat im House Rules,
wir machen mal, wir schaffen hier mal ein Forum, wir laden mal nicht Leute ein.
Diese eine Ladung, die ist jetzt mal persönlich.
Ich möchte mal mit dir sprechen. Ein uns bekannter Musikant hat ja auch bei
einem Treffen die Idee zu einem Lied gehabt,
weil da ein Ladender mal über die Kunstfreiheit gesprochen hat.
Der Jean erinnert sich, ist glaube ich auch öffentlich dokumentiert,
dass Jean darüber gesprochen hat,
was alles von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt ist und daraus ein Lied entstanden ist,
ein Pianostück, das viele von uns kennen.
Das ist jetzt kein Geheimtreffen gewesen, aber das war ein persönliches Treffen.
Wo es einen geschlossenen Einladungskreis gibt.
Ich zum Beispiel auch häufig den Jean einlade und sage, sag dem Tim bitte nicht
Bescheid. Und das ist ja ganz normal. Ja.
Ich finde es immer merkwürdig, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch wichtig, dass man mal unterschätzt.
Also das ist schon relativ normal, dass es natürlich, man nennt das,
also andere Begriffe dafür sind Seilschaften, Netzwerke.
was könnte man da noch zu sagen?
Was weiß ich, aber die haben was geplant und das ist entscheidend. Natürlich.
Die haben was geplant und das war sicherlich auch nicht das erste Mal, dass sie sich...
Und da gibt es auch noch andere und jetzt kommt alles zu Licht.
Und jetzt sagen alle, uh, auf welcher Party habe ich schon geflirtet?
Uh, da soll ich aufpassen.
Rennen auf uns zu und sagen, ich muss euch das ganz schnell sagen,
bevor ihr es rausfindet. Das ist interessant.
Und das ist der Moment, wo man sagt, aha, du hast in allem, also du hast ja
jetzt so viele Reaktionen, Nicht nur, dass alle, die bei diesem Treffen waren,
persönlich Konsequenzen finden.
Sondern du hast die ganzen Unternehmen, die sich da zusammentun und sagen, so geht es nicht weiter.
Du hast Redaktionen, die anfangen dazu zu recherchieren. Also früher hattest
du Redaktionen, die sich zusammenschließen, um zu sagen, irgendein Fußballer
hat irgendwen auf einer Party geknutscht und jetzt tun wir zehn Leute aus dem
Spiegel auf dieses Thema.
Weil das ist gerade das ganz große Ding. Das wollen alle wissen.
Da hast du wirklich hochqualifizierte Menschen, die nichts anderes tun,
als diesen Fußballer zu recherchieren.
Und ich frage mich, Leute, was ist denn da los?
Und.
Jetzt hast du aber die Leute, die sagen, okay, jetzt tun wir alle vom Spiegel,
von der Zeit, von Fatz, die tun wir alle mal darauf, wer hat denn mit Nazis
geflirtet und wann und wo und worüber haben die geredet.
Und das ist ein Qualitätserfolg, den darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Das ist richtig viel wert. Natürlich hast du diese Demonstrationen,
wo Menschen zusammenkommen.
Mir hat eine Freundin erzählt, die sehr organisiert ist in der postmigrantischen
Szene und die meinte, ich habe
da das selten erlebt, dass Menschen aus den Behörden, wo sie arbeitet,
zusammen mit Postmigranten, die selber Postmigrantin, aber zusammen mit anderen
Postmigranten, mit anderen Postmigranten, mit Linken, mit Recht,
also sozusagen Rechtes, Lager, Bürgerlich, CDU,
und alle zusammenkommen, wo man merkt, die würden sonst nicht zusammenkommen.
Ich habe bei der Tagesschau, das hat mich so berührt, da sagt einer,
ich bin einer der Leute, die zu wenig auf die Straße Ich habe jetzt das Bein
meines Kinderbettes abgemacht und die Gardine abgehangen und daraus eine Flagge
gemacht. Ich denke mir, das arme Kind.
Aber das schwappt da über, wo man merkt, wir müssen jetzt was tun.
Und du hast Juristen, die Juristenverbände, die sich zusammentun und sagen, so geht's nicht weiter.
Und du hast, und wir müssen uns jetzt überlegen, was können wir denn juristisch
alles tun, um eventuell AfD-Verbot zu prüfen und und und.
Also da passiert grad überall Dinge von Menschen, die bis jetzt nicht politisch
waren und jetzt aufstehen und sagen, es reicht mir.
Und glaubst du, dass, also wird das halten? Auf eine Weise eigentlich ganz interessant.
Ich meine, mit den Kommunisten haben sie es jahrelang hingekriegt.
Also wenn du jetzt in Richtung McCarthyism guckst oder so, da könnte man sagen, da hat eine,
jetzt benutze ich viele Begriffe im falschen Kontext, aber die wehrhafte Demokratie mal so funktioniert.
Also eine absolute Hexenjagd gegen Leute, die für soziale Gleichheit waren,
aber den man jetzt... Ne.
Soziale Gleichheit, aber auch Autoritarismus. Kommunisten sind auch sehr autoritätsfreundlich.
Im McCarthy-Ism ist ein oder andere Opfer, gab es da glaube ich auch noch was.
Aber da ist ein oder andere Sozialdemokrat noch unter die Räder gekommen. Aber okay.
Ja.
Hält dieses Momentum an oder nicht?
Okay, ich bin ja kein Prophet, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Aber du bist es ja natürlich.
Was ich spannend finde, ist, dass jetzt zumindest ein Momentum da ist,
dass jetzt gemerkt wird, ey okay, jetzt können wir endlich überprüfen,
was ich getan hätte, wenn ich in der Situation meiner Großeltern gewesen wäre.
Ich glaube, das ist einer der stärksten Sprüche, die ich auf Demos gesehen habe.
Was hätte ich getan? Die Fakten sind offengelegt. Die Maske ist jetzt runtergezogen.
Wir wissen, was der Plan ist.
Mit Sicherheit nicht von allen AfDlern. Das sind bestimmt auch ein paar Verstrahlte
da, die dachten, das wollte ich aber jetzt nicht.
Aber der Großteil, und das haben ja auch viele aus der Parteispitze bestätigt,
beziehungsweise aus der Partei, haben gesagt, das ist kein Geheimplan,
das ist ein Versprechen.
Das war ja wirklich auch mit der härtesten Tweet überhaupt. Das ist kein Geheimplan,
das ist ein Versprechen. Wir werden Millionen hier hier rauswerfen.
Das ist völlig klar. Und jetzt kann man sagen, okay, was machen wir damit?
Und wir wissen es nicht. Gerade sind die Demos überschlagen sich und es wird jeden Tag krasser.
Das finde ich sehr beachtlich. Die Frage ist, wie sehr bleiben die Leute dran?
Mein Job jetzt als Redakteur ist nicht zu Demos aufzurufen, sondern weiter zu
recherchieren. Das machen wir auch.
Wir bekommen alle möglichen Hinweise. Denen gehen wir nach.
Wenn wir es nicht selber schaffen, dann geben wir die weiter.
Das ist sozusagen ganz normale journalistische Arbeit, die wir machen.
In einem Bereich, der halt mal eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, kein Problem.
So nebenbei, ich habe gestern Abend mit einem Journalisten noch geschrieben,
der mich darauf hinwies, dass auf bild.de, wenn du auf diese Seite gegangen bist,
Blocker aus oder was auch immer, da war keine Erwähnung dieser Demonstration. Was?
Keine Erwähnung dieser Demonstration, null. Nupp, das ist gar nichts.
Gestern?
Und heute Morgen auch nicht. Heute Morgen habe ich dann nochmal geschaut,
dachte so, okay, vielleicht waren die Bild-Redakteure alle noch verkatert oder
so. Oder vielleicht waren die selber auf der Demo, nix.
Heute Morgen Bild geguckt, Meldung Nummer eins war irgendwas mit Dschungelcamp
und Fußball oder sowas. Also die haben das komplett...
Ich halte auch keinen ordentlichen Journalismus, muss man sagen. Ja.
Also genau, ordentlicher Journalismus ist eine Sache, aber du musst es schon
schaffen, das halt wirklich gezielt tot zu schweigen.
Da gab es dann irgendwo unter Regional oder irgendwie, wenn du auf News gegangen
bist, bei Bild.de, immerhin ist News halt eine Unterkategorie.
Wenn du da draufgeklickt hast, dann kam irgendwas zu den Demonstrationen.
Aber es war jetzt schon so, dass eigentlich jede Startseite,
also wenn du auf Tagesschau gegangen bist.
Wenn du auf Washington Post, New York Times, also Washington Post hat irgendwie
sieben oder acht Artikel dazu gemacht.
Das ist schon Berichterstattung einfach. Übrigens nicht nur von Deutschland, das ist interessant.
Du hast auch 160 Demos angemeldet in Frankreich gegen deren neues Migrationsgesetz,
das gegen Grundrechte in Frankreich verstößt. Also es entsteht gerade in Israel
hast du unheimlich viele Leute, die gegen Netanyahu demonstrieren.
Das ist jetzt kein Phänomen, das nur wegen unseres Artikels rauskommt.
Also das möchte ich auch festhalten.
Wir haben gerade glaube ich schon eine Art globalen Backlash und das macht auch
Hoffnung, was USA angeht, gegen Trump, gegen autoritäre Regime.
Da muss man sagen, ein letztes Aufbäumen?
Oder schaffen wir es, uns zu wehren?
Wissen wir nicht. Aber es passiert gerade endlich was und da war...
Da war der Artikel sicherlich ein Weckruf, aber eben nicht die Ursache, die alleinige.
Also der hatte Tropfen, der das wasserns.
Der war einfach der Moment. Und das glaube ich auch, wenn du fragst,
wie kam, wieso so viele Reaktionen.
Also das eine habe ich schon gesagt, die Demaskierung, der Moment und so.
Und das ist einfach so unter dem Brennglas klar geworden, worum es geht.
Aber du hast auch einen Moment, das ist zumindest mein Gefühl,
dass eine solche Ohnmacht sich aufgestaut hat.
Erstmal nach Corona. Ja, was willst du machen? machen.
Boah, das war alles so einengend. Dann hast du den Russland-Angriff auf die
Ukraine. Dann hast du den 7. Oktober in Israel.
Das waren alles Momente, wo wir da standen und dachten, fuck,
fuck, fuck, ey, was kann ich denn machen? Was hab ich in der Hand?
Und jetzt hast du plötzlich dieses Treffen in Deutschland, wo du merkst,
okay, ich bin betroffen als Mensch mit Nazi-Hintergrund oder Mensch mit Jetzt
reicht es mir, ich gehe auf die Straße und die ganze Kraft geht raus Und es reicht mir.
Also das ist, glaube ich, sozusagen das Aufsprudeln der Ohnmachtlosigkeit.
Aber wie blickst du denn jetzt zum Beispiel darauf, also als jemand,
der jetzt an dieser Recherche beteiligt war, der sich ja offenbar sehr mit den
dort anwesenden Personen auskennt,
wie blickst du denn jetzt zum Beispiel auf diese Konzentration auf die AfD?
Wie meinst du?
Naja, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, hat sich gestern die Werteunion,
also der Parteiversuch um Hans-Georg Maaßen,
gegründet, in dem Foto, was da,
also ein Foto, was auch an Peinlichkeit nicht zu überbieten ist,
dann halten sie zwei Deutschlandflaggen hin, die haben ja noch tausend Knicke
aus der Amazon-Verpackung, ja,
also die hatten offenbar keine Deutschlandfahnen zur Hand und mussten sich die
noch bei Amazon gefaltet kaufen,
ja, ich meine, das erste, wenn man eine Fahne kauft, das erste,
was man macht, ist, man haut die, verknüttelt die und haut die in die Waschmaschine,
damit niemand sieht, dass man die gerade erst gekauft hat. Selbst dafür hatten die keine Zeit.
Ja, hast du dich schon mal gefragt, wozu es Amazon Same-Day-Delivery gibt für solche Notfälle?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du so flaggenstilbewusst bist.
Ich bin flaggenstilbewusst.
Meine Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Einhorn-Standarte-Flagge. Ich bin auch sehr froh,
dass sie jetzt inzwischen durch mehrere Aufenthalte in Gewitter und schlechtem
Wetter so leichte Fetzen am Ende hängen.
dass sie jetzt so richtig, jetzt kriegt die Patina, jetzt hat die Geschichte und so immerhin.
Haben sie keine belgische Flagge da gehabt.
Weiß man nicht,
aber zwei bei diesem Treffen der Gründung der Werteunion, zwei anwesende Personen
bei diesem Treffen und zwar die Simone Baum und Silke.
Schneider ich weiß nicht, ob Manuela oder Michaela Michaelaschneider.
Ich habe es selber gemacht und wohnt. Ich gucke mal schnell bei mir.
Michaelaschneider, glaube ich. Ja.
Michaelaschneider.
War auch so ein No-Man's-Wort, was man mit Google nicht finden konnte.
Da muss man schon viel suchen, bis man das Gesicht erkannte. Ja, okay.
Also die beiden sind da und dann?
Ja, und da gründet sich gerade die nächste Partei. Also da sollte sich ja schon,
Simone Baum und Michael Schneider genauso.
Und ich guckte diese Tim, so kannst du doch nicht. Das ist doch,
das gehört doch unter Strafe.
Das ist doch hier diese gefaltete Flagge. Das ist doch irgendwie,
damit kannst du doch Also.
Beschwer dich mal nicht, dass man Deutschland zusammenfaltet. So.
Jetzt regt euch mal ab. Ich würde gerne mal darüber reden wollen.
Also ich war ja auch auch auf dieser Demo. Ich habe mir dann auch diese Reden,
angehört. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich mich generell mit Demos und der Demokultur
so ein bisschen schwer tue.
Ich weiß nicht, warum immer alle die ganze Zeit schreien müssen.
Also wozu hat man da ein Mikrofon und einen Lautsprecher?
Ja, das ist laut genug, aber es muss immer die ganze Zeit alles immer geschrien
werden, um irgendwie seinem also ich weiß nicht, also bei mir kommt das nicht
so an, dass damit irgendwas unterstrichen wird.
Kannst auch mal ganz vernünftig was recherchieren und publizieren. ganz leise.
Also man kann natürlich schon ein bisschen Emotionalität haben,
aber es ist halt von verschiedenen Vortragenden wurde einfach der Schreistil gepflegt.
Und das ist schön.
Habe ich auch noch hingenommen, was ich ein bisschen vermisst habe,
ich meine, nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie so eine Martin Luther King Rede erwartet
hätte, aber die Gelegenheit,
wenn man so 250.000 Leute da stehen hat, gut, die werden wahrscheinlich auch
mit ihren Lautsprechern nicht weit gekommen, aber es ist auch auch irgendwie
alles gestreamt worden, wie auch immer.
Es wurde halt viel über so, wir sind die Brandmauer,
die keiner aufhält. Ich weiß nicht, Brandmauern bewegen sich jetzt offensichtlich.
Ey Tim, jetzt kannst du die so vereindeutsche Sprache...
Ich fand die Bilder halt ein bisschen schwierig. So, und okay,
kann ich auch alles noch irgendwie hinnehmen.
Mir fehlte nur so ein wenig, also es wurde viel beschworen, dass jetzt alle
zusammen sind und sind alle gegen irgendwas.
Was mir aber einfach gefehlt hat, war dieses, was machen wir jetzt damit,
was ist wichtig, weil es ist ja auch klar, diese Demos werden nicht ewig weitergehen,
sondern das wird sein Ende finden im News-Cycle, in der Erschöpfung.
Leute werden denken, ich war ja schon ein-, zwei- oder dreimal jetzt auf einer
Demo, jetzt habe ich ja auch genug getan und dann droht es sozusagen,
okay, vielleicht glaubst Du glaubst es nicht, aber mir fehlte sozusagen die
Ansage in dieser Hinsicht.
Die Frage ist, was muss geschehen? Meiner Auffassung nach muss es halt jetzt
einfach mal eine klare Erkenntnis geben, dass das halt...
sich im Wesentlichen eigentlich in Wahlbeteiligung ausdrücken muss.
Ja, gut. Also Wahlbeteiligung kannst du machen. Finde ich auch wichtig.
Wollen wir hoffen. Habe ich keinen direkten Einfluss drauf.
Also mit den Personen, die jetzt konkret auf dieser Demo waren.
Es werden ja jetzt nicht alle anfangen.
So effektivistisch zu werden. Aber da bist du, glaube ich, wenn du das auf Wahlbeteiligung,
hast du ein Demokratieverständnis, was sehr, will ich dir jetzt nicht unterstellen,
aber sehr verengt ist. Nämlich alle vier Jahre einmal Kreuz machen.
Es gibt ja dazwischen noch sehr, sehr sehr viel, nämlich zivilgesellschaftliches
Engagement und auch, und das muss man an der Stelle, da wird sehr viel diskutiert,
ein AfD-Verbot einzuleiten.
Und wenn das AfD-Verbot eingeleitet wird und darauf kann man Druck ausüben.
Dann ist die Frage für mich einzig und allein nicht das Ob, sondern das Wie.
Denn das Ob, da bin ich jetzt als Nicht-Jurist der Überzeugung,
dass die Belege auf dem Tisch jetzt liegen.
Nicht nur von uns, sondern auch vom Spiegel und von anderen Zeitungen,
die jetzt weiter daran arbeiten,
Da hast du eigentlich genug Material, wenn man sich das KPD-Urteil anguckt,
wo das ja schon durchexitiert wurde und KPD wurde verboten, dann kann man sagen, die AfD,
glaube ich, ist da wirklich ein Pfeil für ein Verfassungsgericht.
Wird das denn verboten? Dann hast du natürlich ein Problem.
Dann hast du 30% der Deutschen, oder 20 oder was, die sagen,
ich wollte gerade da ein Kreuz machen, jetzt kann ich doch kein Kreuz machen, was machen wir jetzt?
Gut, dann kannst du Wagenknecht gehen, kannst du Maaßen gehen,
kannst du im Bündnis Deutschland gehen, da gibt es Alternativangebote, kannst du alle machen.
Aber trotzdem glaube ich, dann ist die Frage, wie kann man das politisch auffangen?
Und welche Instrumente Und da rede ich jetzt aus zwei Richtungen.
Das eine sind die Parteien, also Grüne, FDP, SPD, CDU und Die Linke.
Was macht ihr, damit ihr nicht im Verdacht seid, dass ihr einfach nur irgendwen
verbieten wollt, die euch nicht wählen wollen.
Und aber auch, was machen wir denn als TV-Gesellschaft? Wir sind ja nicht entlassen,
nur weil wir einmal im Jahreskreuz waren.
Das heißt, ich weiß, ich bin da jetzt kein Experte, das ist ja auch nicht mein
Job, aber eine Idee, die mir in den Kopf kommt, ist Bürgerräte in jedem fucking Dorf aufzubauen.
Entschuldigung, wenn ich fucking gesagt habe, feine deutsche Sprache.
Also in jedem Dorf aufzubauen. Fickend.
Fickend heißt das. Fickend. Ein korpulierendes Bürgerräte zu machen.
Nee, im Ernst. Also irgendwelche Auffangmöglichkeiten zu machen.
Und ich muss da ja auch schon sagen.
Und Parteien, so wie sie heute agieren, die großen Parteien,
glaubst du denen ein Wort, das sie sagen mit ihrem ganzen PR-Management?
Hast du nicht das Gefühl, dass ein Scholz heute das sagt und morgen das sagt?
Da ist ja ein großes Misstrauen zu Recht entstanden mit Cum-Ex.
Das ist ja nicht so, als wäre das Misstrauen irgendwie daher fantasiert.
Ja, und was mich halt fasziniert, ist, dass dann so ein Habeck,
der versucht hat, mal Tacheles zu reden und zu sagen, ey, wir leben hier in
Widersprüchen, das ist alles nicht einfach, wir werden jetzt für schwierige Sachen.
Der hat ja mal einen anderen Kommunikationsstil gemacht und trotzdem wird er gejagt.
Also wir haben da noch keine kommunikative Lösung, weil die Kommunikation ist nicht alles.
Das heißt, eine andere Sprache oder ein anderes Thema ist Gerechtigkeit.
Gehen wir mal in Eigentum ran? Können wir Umverteilung mal anfassen?
Ist das was, was wir uns auch überlegen müssen als Lösung?
Das ist erst ein riesen Diskurs. Wie fängst du das auf, wenn du die sogenannten
Sorgen der Bürger ernst nehmen willst? Ja, dann musst du Umverteilung machen.
Das ist mein Vorschlag. Vielleicht gibt es auch andere Wege.
Aber wie kann man das aufmachen?
Also Umverteilung auf jeden Fall, aber von unten nach oben oder von oben nach unten jetzt?
Von links nach rechts. Rechts nach links. Ja.
Aber jetzt bist du bei politischen Maßnahmen angekommen und ich habe jetzt explizit
davon gesprochen, was machen die Leute, die jetzt aufgeschreckt sind und sozusagen bereit waren,
zumindest schon mal auf eine Demo zu gehen, weil sie ein Standing haben wollen. Was ist es?
Die gucken in ihrem direkten Umfeld erstmal. Wen kenne ich da,
wer die AfD wählt? Wen kenne ich da, der organisiert ist?
Was kann ich denn da machen, um den Faschismus zu bekämpfen?
Also gehen wir wirklich mental mal an, und das ist wirklich nur ein Gedankenexperiment,
das ist kein Vergleich, das ist ein Gedanke an 1933.
Was wäre, wenn ich in der Zeit wäre und ich würde sehen, irgendeine Tante und
Onkel von mir sagt, naja, das ist ja gar nicht so schlimm und das machen wir jetzt mal.
Was mache ich dann? Und dann sei kreativ. Also es gibt so viele Wege.
Bist du Jurist, machst du das. Bist du Journalist, machst du das.
Bist du irgendwie, was weiß ich, Landwirt, dann sagst du, ey,
pass mal auf, lass uns gerne für Agrarsachen demonstrieren, aber vielleicht
für solidarische Landwirtschaft und für eine Umverteilung und so weiter.
Also überleg dir gut, was du machst, damit du, wenn du etwas tust,
die Nazis nicht applaudieren.
Das ist die Folie, die auf jede deiner Handlungen drauflegen muss.
Ich finde das einen schönen Wunsch. Ich glaube noch nicht so richtig daran,
dass die Landwirte das erhören werden.
Weil das muss man sich nur die letzten Wochen ja anschauen, wie es gelaufen ist.
Es gibt super coole Landwirte. Ja.
Natürlich gibt es super coole Leute, aber wir reden jetzt wirklich mal von dem
Großteil der Gesellschaft.
Und man wählt auch nicht nur alle vier Jahre. Man wählt eigentlich fast jedes
Jahr. Ja, man wählt immer irgendwas.
Man hat Europawahl, man hat Regionalwahl, man hat irgendwie Kommunal-, also Landeswahl etc.
Also es gibt vielfältige Möglichkeiten immer wieder in irgendeiner Form was zu machen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel, habt ihr das mitbekommen, in Polen gab es ja sogar eine
Aktivität von jungen Leuten, die sich alle wieder in ihren Heimatorten gemeldet
haben, drei Monate vor der Wahl,
um dort sozusagen die Stimmenmehrheiten auf dem Land ein wenig zu beeinflussen.
Das ist wohl ein richtig großes Ding gewesen, die sechsstellige Zahl von Leuten, die das gemacht haben.
Es gibt auch gerade eine Bewegung in Deutschland.
Könnte man in Thüringen auch mal machen.
Ja, es gibt eine Bewegung von Leuten, die aus Thüringen und Sachsen und so weiter
weggezogen sind, sich wieder dort zu melden, um dort zu wählen.
Why not? Ich meine, ähm.
Nichts davon ist jetzt das Allheilmittel, aber ich denke halt,
dass tatsächlich auch dort und vor allem wahrscheinlich für die meisten Leute
es im Rahmen der Wahlen jetzt die Möglichkeit gibt,
leicht einen Unterschied zu machen.
Das sollte man schon nochmal darauf hinweisen. Wir machen das auf jeden Fall jetzt mal.
Eines, also ich meine,
die Einsicht, die ja irgendwie vermittelt werden muss, ist, dass wir die politischen
Herausforderungen, die irgendwie vor und um uns stehen, gemeinsam bewältigen müssen.
Und dass es nicht so ist, dass, also selten war der Feind irgendwie ärmer als wir.
Und ohnehin schon unterdrückter als wir.
Also es ist ein relativ einfacher Check ist so, ist die Person,
die du gerade für deine Unzufriedenheit verantwortlich machst,
privilegierter als du oder weniger privilegiert?
Wenn sie weniger privilegiert ist, bist du im Zweifelsfall irgendwie nicht auf dem richtigen Weg.
Ja, weil Privilegien akkumulieren sich oben, genauso wie das Kapital sich an
einigen Stellen akkumuliert und das ist, die Idee der Politik ist dem entgegenzuwirken
oder die Idee der Demokratie ist dem entgegenzuwirken.
Deswegen sind wir den weiten Weg gegangen von Gewaltherrschaft über Monarchien
und sonstigen Unterdrückungen, aus denen wir uns alles rausgekämpft haben, in die Demokratie.
Und natürlich gibt es eine ganze Menge Leute, die mir nicht gefallen,
mit denen ich nichts zu tun haben will und denen jetzt vielleicht auch nicht
meine unbedingte, unmittelbare Aufmerksamkeit gilt, aber das heißt noch lange
nicht, dass ich es zum primären Ziel mache,
die auszuschließen von einer Teilhabe an der Gesellschaft.
So bescheuert, so wahnsinnige Ideen, wie Donald Trump hat irgendwie mit einer
Grenze zum Staat Mexiko, die dann irgendwie den größten Teil des Zementvorkommens
des Planeten benötigt. Nein, das ist jetzt übertrieben.
Du meinst die Mauer, nicht die Grenze.
Die Mauer, die Grenze gibt es ja, aber der wollte ja da eine Mauer hin machen.
Also so irrsinnige Ideen, wo man sich überlegt, die Gesellschaft,
die man für die Zukunft haben möchte,
die muss ja mit einer Utopie verbunden sein.
Die müssen ja auch Leute mitmachen.
Ja.
Du kannst ja nicht, es geht ja nicht zu sagen, wir haben eine gesellschaftliche
Utopie, dass hier alle eine weiße Hautfarbe haben und alles was wir dafür brauchen
ist so und so viele Millionen Menschen aus diesem Land vertreiben,
da ist doch kein Problem mit gelöst.
Ganz im Gegenteil, du hast eine ganze Menge neuer Probleme.
Du hast eine ganze Menge neuer Probleme, unter anderem, dass auf einmal eine
ganze Menge Arbeit nicht gemacht wird.
Und zwar die ganzen Knowledge Worker und die intelligenten Leute,
die uns in diesem Land fehlen und die wir brauchen,
um den Osten zu zivilisieren, der jetzt 15, 20 Jahre Braindrain hatte,
die müssen ja irgendwo herkommen.
Ja und das ist also wirklich so, es ist halt wirklich scheiße,
dass wir gerade eine Menge komplexer Probleme haben und auch Schwierigkeiten
damit haben, uns diesen Problemen,
Ja, stabil gegenüberzustellen und uns gut gegen diese Probleme zu positionieren.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass eines der, also wirklich keines der Probleme,
dass so eine AfD-Wählerin um den Schlaf bringt,
wird dadurch gelöst, dass du irgendwie mit riesigem Aufwand Menschen aus diesem Land vertreibst.
Also keines. Kein einziges.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Und das ist doch die Einsicht, die irgendwie vermittelt werden muss.
Ja.
Gut.
Kommen wir nochmal zu lustigen Sachen. Jemand hatte ein Saunaboot.
Jawohl.
Was ich eine sehr gute Idee finde bei einer Recherche, die im September.
November.
November, November, Entschuldigung natürlich, November.
An meinem Geburtstag haben die sich getroffen. Das ist ja auch kein Zufall. Sauerei.
Also wenn ich im November,
recherchieren müsste, würde ich auch sagen, wenn ich mich dann auch noch an
der frischen Luft aufhalten muss, würde ich schon sagen,
Saunaboot.
Also worauf du anspielen möchtest ist, es wurde das Ganze ja technisch begleitet,
unter anderem auch fotografisch und es gab verschiedene Winkel,
von denen Fotos gemacht wurden und einer war halt von Süden aus,
da wo der schöne Lenitzsee ist, wo das Gästehaus ja liegt.
Genau. Also das Lustige ist, bei der Rezeption lag so ein Flyer aus.
Übrigens lag da ein Flyer aus auch von, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der heißt, Fotobox Peters oder so.
Und da konnte man sich so einen Fotografen mieten, der so eine Fotobox aufstellt.
Da sind wir nicht drauf gekommen.
Das wäre natürlich genial gewesen, so einen lustigen Fotografen,
der so Erinnerungsfotos macht mit allen Gästen.
Mit Nazis, also so ein schönes Porträt mit lustigem Mut oder so.
Aber es gab auch das Seekult. Also allen, die jetzt gerne mal eine Saunaerfahrung
machen wollen auf dem Saunaboot in Potsdam, empfehle ich hier an der Stelle Seekult.
Die hatten da Flyer ausliegen und man konnte sich ein Saunaboot mieten,
zwei Kilometer entfernt und damit direkt bis dahin schippern.
Das haben wir uns natürlich nicht zweimal überlegt, sondern gedacht,
ja super, wie können wir denn hier Fotos machen von vorn, von hinten?
Greenpeace an der Stelle will ich auch erwähnen, haben Autos dahingestellt und
von der einen Seite, von den Eingangskameras observiert,
haben so alles zur Verfügung gestellt und Seekult hat uns, uns wissen wir wen,
aber einfach ein Daunafloß zur Verfügung gestellt, mit dem wir fünf Meter entfernt
von der Wiese, die direkt an dem Hotel war,
Haben wir dann geankert, oder ich war nicht dabei, aber Kolleginnen waren da drauf.
Und das war, also da hast du drei Leute drauf, der eine mit so einem Telesport-Objektiv,
die andere Person war mit verfrorenen...
Siehst du das jetzt hier auf dieser Welt?
Genau das.
Gab es gar Rabatt hier, Rabattaktion. Unter der Woche, im November, ja.
Ja, aber war dann, also die andere Person war dann am Motor...
Die eine hat sich mal aufgefärbt und der andere musste Fotos machen.
Aber die andere Person war am Motor immer sozusagen mit gefrorenen Händen und
die dritte war mit so Ferngläsern und hat immer gesagt, ja fünf Meter vor,
fünf Meter zurück und dann und dann,
Fotos gemacht und es war genau, das war eine ganz schöne das war natürlich lustig,
weil es mit allem Engagement,
Fotos gemacht wurden, aber wir hatten auch auch ein Reporter,
also es waren verschiedene Perspektiven.
Das eine waren wie gesagt diese Autos mit Dashcams drin, das andere waren die
Sauna-Flows, das dritte war ein Reporter, der drin war, mit seiner Uhr da gefilmt hat,
mit so einer Uhr, die eine Kamera drin hat und er hat ja mittlerweile jede zweite
Uhr und da rumgelaufen und so einen Kaffee gefragt hat.
Das waren quasi die drei Perspektiven, die wir hatten, um zu gucken,
dass wir die wirklich alle erkennen können und unsere Quellen uns da ja sozusagen
nicht nur erzählen müssen, sondern, oder wir das von den Quellen bekommen, wer da wahr sein.
Das war ja auch wirklich ein Highlight in dem Bühnenstück, was wir nochmal würdigen
sollten zum Ende der Sendung.
Ich war ja vor Ort und mir das irgendwie angeschaut und Das Bühnenstück meinst
du jetzt? Das Bühnenstück.
Ja.
Moment mal.
Die haben wir aber nicht auf der Kamera gehabt. Das haben wir gekauft.
Weißt du, Obsekt, ne? Ne, ich war im Berliner Ensemble bei dem Stück,
wo wir schon erwähnt haben, dass du da Autor, Autor, Co-Autor,
ich weiß nicht, du hast das mit den Leuten zusammen...
Lolita Lachs und Kai Vogels, ja, das sind die zwei, mit denen ich das gemacht habe. Ja.
Ich fand das eine sehr würdige Veranstaltung und die auf der einen Seite das gut rübergebracht hat.
Ich bin gar nicht so ein Theatertyp, muss ich dazu sagen. Ich hab's irgendwie
nicht so mit Theater, aber das hab ich alles sehr genossen.
Gibt's übrigens bei, in der ARD Mediathek, kann man sich das mal angucken.
Und auf YouTube da auch noch, oder? YouTube.
Genau, überall.
Ich war ja leider gezwungen, meine vier Karten zu verschenken. Eine an Tim.
Und musste es im Stream schauen. Da war, während das gestreamt wurde,
waren ja schon 19.000 Leute da drin.
Das Ding hat jetzt irgendwie eine Viertelmillion Millionen Views auf YouTube.
Für einen Theaterfilm abfilmen, ist das irgendwie nicht so üblich.
Ja.
Das dürfen gerne auch noch ein paar mehr werden, weil ich fand das einfach eine sehr,
gute Zusammenfassung des Geschehens, wo dann halt auch diese witzigen Elemente
eben wie mit dem Saunafloß oder mit dem nach Kaffee gefragt Mann so wunderbar rüber kam. Oder Frau.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, also im Stück war es ein Mann.
Ne, es war eine Schauspielerin mit Bart.
Echt?
Ja.
Oh.
Okay, alles klar.
Sorry, jetzt hätte ich mal bessere Plätze bekommen müssen.
Sorry.
Der Hasolinos war echt jetzt hier. Ey.
Ihr hattet so weit vorne gesessen.
Okay, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, schönes Detail.
Sprachdeutscher Sprachverein, hallo. Ja.
Also mehr kann ich da eigentlich auch gar nicht zu sagen, außer dass ich ich
allen nochmal empfehlen möchte, da mal reinzuschauen.
Ich glaube, was ich da gerne verarbeiten wollte, ist das Problem,
das immer wieder im Stück aufkommt, wie sagst es denn?
Und das ist das, was wir, also da kommt der Faschismus und die Reporter dürfen
nicht sagen, das ist der Faschismus, sondern die müssen sagen, das sind irgendwie.
Parteimitglieder der Partei, die vom
Verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem eingeordnet wird, aber das sind halt,
Einfach Faschisten. Und dass du mittlerweile in einer Situation bist,
wo du jedes Wort dreimal umdrehen musst, bevor du das benennen kannst,
was da vor uns steht, das haben wir versucht so ein bisschen dort auszuarbeiten.
Ja, sozusagen, das ist glaube ich das Künstlerische, also abgesehen davon,
dass man das erlebbar machen sollte, also die Idee, warum wir das denn überhaupt
gemacht haben, ist ja, dass man nach, also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Buch von Björn Schulhand kennt,
wo er über die Erzählungen und Narrationen, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt,
Björn Schulhand hat so ein kleines Büchlein geschrieben.
Und da beschreibt er, wie Informationen auf uns einprasseln und wir quasi auf
dem Handy swipen von Tiger Baby über Ukraine Krieg und gar nicht mehr richtig
verarbeiten können, die Aufmerksamkeit, die da gelenkt wird.
Was ist jetzt wichtig und was nicht? Und dem gegenüber stellt er vor 200 Jahren
oder was, wenn der Bote kommt von der spanischen Revolution und dann alle da sitzen und hören,
was hat das mit mir zu tun und da ist sozusagen die Kunde, die erzählt wird und es wird erlebt.
Und wir sitzen am Lagerfeuer und erleben was und können das richtig gemeinsam
diskutieren, verarbeiten.
Diesen Moment wollte ich schaffen, wollten wir schaffen im Theatersaal,
dass man da gemeinsam dieses Momentum erleben kann, verstehen kann,
einordnen kann, von Anfang bis Ende, nicht nur die Headline.
Und dann auch den Kontext versteht. Moment mal, was darf ich denn sagen und
was nicht und wie und was und was das Problem und das.
Im Journalismus gepaart, also Fakten rüberzubringen und sie immer wieder geschichtlich
und eben in dem aktuellen Diskurs einzuordnen. Das war quasi die Aufgabe.
Es gab ja nicht nur positive Rezeptionen des Theaterstücks, also ich fand es super.
Soll auch so sein.
Ja.
Das kann auch so sein.
Es hatte Also ich fand es sehr gelungen, es hatte seine humorvollen Aspekte,
genau dieses mit dem, nee, das darf man nicht sagen, das ist so ein bisschen
die redaktionelle Arbeit,
ein bisschen auch, man merkt den, ja wie soll man das sagen,
den Frust des Redakteurs, den du jetzt auch gerade,
einen oder anderen Lacher, aber natürlich auch den einen oder anderen Lacher,
der dann so im Halse stecken bleibt.
Es ist natürlich so eine offene, also es wurde euch glaube ich ein bisschen
so zur Last gelegt, diese todernste
Recherche und Enthüllung hier ins Theater zu bringen oder so, ne?
Ich konnte mir jetzt bei der Kritik die...
Da möchte ich ganz klar sagen, also diese Recherche ist ein Schlag in den Magen
von einem Menschen, der seit Jahrzehnten Rassismus erlebt.
Der erlebt es jeden Tag und dann kommt diese diese Recherche und ich habe gehört
von Schulklassen, die das besprechen und merken, fast jeder in der Schulklasse,
wenn das passiert, würde deportiert werden.
Das ist eine reale Angst.
Das ist kein fucking Witz. Und dann kriegst du mit in diesem bourgeoisen Theater
sitzen da so Weiße und machen Witze.
Das tut doch unheimlich weh. Und dann ist das gesamte die ganzen Schauspielerinnen
und Schauspieler sind also einer da waren nicht alle, aber fast alle sind sozusagen Bio-Deutsche.
Eine Person, das erkennt man nicht so richtig, das kommt nicht aus der Zeit.
Aber das ist sozusagen, und dann, okay, wir haben mit der Beratung von dem Stabiler-Rücken-EV.
Rassismuskritisch, aber das kommt trotzdem, auch in dem Augenblick,
wo du das siehst, ist es egal, das tut einfach fucking weh.
Und da verstehe ich zu sagen, ey Leute, könnt ihr mal das Maul halten,
das ist nicht fucking witzig, das tut weh. und dann feiert ihr euch auch noch
hier als tolle Journalisten und so. Diese Stimme ist wichtig.
Und da will ich auch sagen, das ist zum Teil der Zeit geschuldet.
Wir haben das Stück in...
vier Tagen geschrieben, wir haben zwei Probentage gehabt, da mussten die existierenden
Strukturen, die halt nun mal weiß, rassistisch durchfleucht sind, genutzt werden.
Ich hatte da keinen Raum zu sagen, können wir bitte noch drei Schleifen machen
und eine Ausschreibung machen und Menschen einlassen.
Das wäre jetzt auch ein bisschen, also mein, also jetzt zumindest die Personen,
die die Anwesenden gespielt haben, da wäre jetzt auch Diversity ja...
Ja, aber kann man machen. Also ich finde es nicht falsch. Wir haben auch Frauen,
die Männer gespielt haben, Also es ist egal, alte, die jungen gespielt haben.
Das finde ich alles egal.
Das ist Wumpe an der Stelle.
Wir hätten auch noch andere Autorinnen, wenn wir Zeit gehabt hätten,
das zu machen, dann hätten wir das gemacht.
Und das ist eine valide Kritik an dem Stück erstmal.
Die Zeitachse ist dann nicht mitgerechnet, aber unabhängig davon ist es valide,
das im Theaterbetrieb mitzudenken.
Was ich aber als Antwort auch geben will ist, dass wir dieses Stück,
auf eigene Kosten gemacht haben und alles Open Source gemacht haben man kann
das nutzen, also Open Source im Sinne von der Text ist online,
alle können es nutzen wir kriegen viele Zuschriften, können wir es einfach was
sind die Bedingungen, Lizenzen wir sagen, er antwortet immer,
nutzt es einfach, macht es einfach schreibt es um, macht es anders schreibt
es weiter das ist ganz üblich im Theaterbetrieb, dass man Texte nimmt und sie
umschreibt Und anpasst.
Und das soll bitte und gerne passieren.
Also wenn jemand sagt, ich möchte das im Gorki-Theater nur mit postmigrantischen
Menschen machen und ich möchte den Text komplett umschreiben,
dann seid ihr herzlich eingeladen. Wir freuen uns, dass es passiert.
Wir sind nicht die Krönung des Wortes und des Wissens für deutsche Sprachenvereine.
Jetzt habe ich aber natürlich schon eigentlich vermutet, dass die Sätze,
die da so fallen in dem Theaterstück, dass die ja irgendwie so ein Vorbild haben.
Von der Konferenz.
Also so viel kann man da jetzt nicht ändern.
Doch, du kannst alles ändern. Das ist die Kunstfreiheit. Du kannst alles ändern.
Das ist das Ding. Und es ist auch nicht alles, was da gesagt wird.
Das ist ja das Spiel des Textes. Und Leute, die sich intellektuell damit auseinandersetzen,
werden merken, wo sind die Grenzen und wo nicht.
Das will ich dir zumuten. Dass du dich damit auseinandersetzt,
dass du dir Überlegungen machst, was kann ich hier sagen und was nicht.
Und an welcher Stelle muss ich sagen, das hier ist jetzt frei erfunden.
Und das hier ist jetzt umgeschrieben. Und das hier werde ich jetzt nicht sagen,
weil das Nazis sagen und ich will nichts reproduzieren.
Wir haben es damit gelöst, dass wir Dinge gesagt haben, daraufhin sich Leute
und das war übrigens bei uns in der Redaktion genau so.
Ich habe da eigentlich Redakteure zitiert, die gesagt haben,
das kannst du doch nicht im Text schreiben.
Das ist doch ein Nazi-Ausdruck, nicht assimilierter Staatsbürger.
Der meinte, mein Kollege, wenn du dieses Wort abdruckst, dann machst du die Tür auf zu Buchenwald.
Das ist der direkte Weg ins KZ. Und wir haben gesagt, nee, wir müssen es aber
bringen, weil die das gesagt haben, nicht assimilierte Staatsbürger.
Und dann müssen wir es aber einordnen und sagen, das verstößt gegen das Grundgesetz. selbst.
Und das haben wir dann genauso reflektiert im Theaterstück, dass wir gesagt
haben, der sagt das und dann regt sich jemand auf und sagt, halt dein Maul.
Das kannst du nicht sagen.
Und wenn andere sagen, das wollen wir überhaupt nicht reproduzieren,
dann sollen die das bitte genauso spielen. Das ist willkommen.
Und wenn andere sagen, wir wollen das nochmal ein bisschen irgendwie mehr kontextualisieren
und wollen andere Stimmen reinbringen aus der postmigrantischen Community, dann bitte.
Also es ist wichtig zu verstehen, wir haben da da etwas angestoßen und ich habe
das übrigens noch nie erlebt und das sagt auch mein Kollege Kai Vogels aus dem Theater,
er hat es noch nie erlebt, dass so sehr alle Theater in einem Strang,
sonst ist das so viel Konkurrenz in der Kulturwelt.
Und Hans ist in Dortmund.
Nee, der ist Intendant vom Volkstheater Wien, der war in Dortmund.
Wir kennen uns aus Dortmund, wir haben uns dann getroffen beim Chaos Computer
Club und haben das da das erste Mal besprochen.
Beim Kongress, nicht beim...
Beim letzten Chaos Computer Club Kongress, ich kenne ihn seit langem,
aber da haben wir uns nochmal verabredet und,
Deshalb hat er das erste Mal Inhalte aus der Recherche grob gehört,
nicht im Detail, weil wir das natürlich sozusagen noch unter Verschluss halten mussten.
Was meinst du mit, die ziehen alle an einem Strang, also was heißt das konkret?
Das heißt, dass die nicht sagen, hier, ihr seid geil, ihr seid nicht geil,
wir sind besser als ihr und konkurrenz, wir wollen Preise gewinnen und so.
Das ist ein ganz großes Haifischbecken, die Kulturindustrie in der Theaterwelt,
da haben wirklich viele gesagt, können wir das auch aufführen,
können wir den Text haben, wir würden das gerne auch. Es wurde live gestreamt
auf ganz vielen Webseiten von.
Ich glaube.
Über 40 Theater in Deutschland. Bundesweit haben das auf ihren Webseiten gezeigt.
Es wurde in Bochum und ich glaube vier oder fünf anderen Theatern live gestreamt im Theater.
Es war in Bochum überfüllt. Die mussten einen zweiten Saal aufmachen,
weil die gesagt haben, das ist so wichtig. Das war sozusagen,
da haben alle gesagt, das ist, jetzt hören wir auf mit der Kritik an,
du bist besser, du bist geiler, du bist Dings.
Wir haben dieses Stück ja wirklich in zwei Probentage, also nicht mal,
jeden Tag waren drei bis vier Stunden.
Und es war kein Stück, was von Exzellenz, also ich muss sagen,
die Schauspieler waren unglaublich toll.
Die Schauspieler waren exzellent.
Die waren unheimliche Profis, die können die Materie sofort verarbeiten.
Aber die hatten auch alle.
Die hatten da so ein Zettelchen, liegen, weil die konnten ja nicht Textfirmen
sein, ist ja auch völlig klar.
Die haben das nicht auswendig gekonnt, aber haben das wirklich bearbeitet.
Wir haben da viel diskutiert und dann kam der eine und meinte,
das kann ich so nicht sagen, lass mal so machen, lass mal ändern.
Die haben wirklich mitgedacht und Kai Vogels Hut ab, also dass der gesagt hat,
ich zieh das durch und mit so einer Werft das gemacht hat und Oliver Rehse vom Berlin Ensemble,
da haben wirklich alle zusammengehalten und gesagt, das ist jetzt wichtig,
das machen wir jetzt einfach.
Und auch an dieser Stelle vielen Dank an Sven Regner, dass der hatte ja eigentlich
diesen Abend. Das war eigentlich sein Abend.
Der hatte eine Lesung aus Kafka gelesen und hat gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau,
was ihr da macht, es klingt wichtig, ich gebe euch die Bühne frei,
ich verkürze mein Programm.
Das ganze Publikum, das zu ihm gekommen ist, ist früher rausgegangen und dann durften wir spielen.
Also Sven Regner, bis auf einen Ausraster, den er mal in Sachen Urüberrechte Musik hatte.
Ein Mann mit einer weißen Weste und das eine, das lassen wir ihm auch gelten, großartige Bücher.
Also Neue Phase Süd, Herr Lehmann und der kleine Bruder.
Absolute Bibeln, Musik sowieso auch. Einer der,
ja doch sehr wichtigen deutschen Kulturschaffenden.
An der Stelle muss ich auch sagen, nicht nur im Kulturbetrieb,
nicht nur die Demos und so weiter.
Du hast auch auf dem Weg dahin, da sagte unser Reporter, hier,
wir wollen undercover gehen, der sagte Funkoptik Berlin sofort,
hier hast du eine Brille, schenken wir dir 300 Euro Brille.
Damit siehst du richtig scheiße aus.
Also wenn man eine scheiß Brille braucht.
Die haben geile Brillen, aber die haben so eine Brille, die sie nicht verkaufen können.
Ja gut, dann war es auch keine 300 Euro wert.
Doch, das habe ich gesehen.
Also super stabile Leute, die Leute von Babylon Berlin haben unterstützt,
haben gleich gesagt, hier sind alle Pläne, die haben da gedreht in dem Haus,
Babylon Berlin wurde dort gedreht, im selben Haus, da haben sie gesagt,
hier sind alle Architekturpläne.
Wer noch die Maskenbildnerin meinte, zack, hier, euer Reporter sollte mir kommen,
mache ich alles kostenlos. Also da ist so eine Grundsolidarität da gewesen,
wo du echt gemerkt hast, an jeder Stelle, wenn du sagst, ich möchte hier gerade
irgendwie gegen die AfD, sofort.
Und das ist schön. Also das war ein beflügelndes Moment, schon vorher.
Ist das die Brille, die hier der Sven Regner auf dem Bild hat?
Keine Kritik jetzt am Stil von Sven Regner.
Sven Regner ist super.
Außer der Ausraster.
Wie gesagt, ein Ausraster für alle.
Ja.
Und Jean, Ich denke, wir können uns auch bei dir kollektiv für das Korrektiv,
Recherchezentrum bedanken.
Mit einer klaren Hierarchie. Einer flachen Hierarchie.
Ja, für die Arbeit, die sicherlich auch eine Menge Mut erfordert hat,
da so reinzugehen. Vielleicht ist das für dich schon vollkommen normal.
Eine Sache möchte ich noch sagen.
Weil das alles haben wir gemacht und ich finde, das ist gut gelaufen.
Das sind unheimlich tolle Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die unheimlich viel stemmen.
Und ich werde euch jetzt verschonen mit dem sozusagen der Lobhudelei gegenüber
meinen Kolleginnen, das wissen die selber.
Und da kommt auch in den letzten Tagen viel rein an Dank und so.
aber was jetzt gerade auch passiert ist, dass die AfD zum Rückschlag ausholt,
und das läuft so dass unter anderem mein Gesicht mit meinem Namen auf AfD Kompakt
auf Twitter Hauptkanal der AfD und auf allen anderen Hauptkanälen der AfD verbreitet wird,
man kann sehen, die haben es hochgeladen, runtergeladen, hochgeladen sie haben
diskutiert, machen wir es, machen wir es nicht ähm,
Eure Community, die das jetzt hört, die soll erstmal, wenn ihr irgendwas machen
könnt, dann ist es alle Angriffe gegen Korrektiv jetzt zu monitoren.
Zu gucken, was machen die jetzt nach diesem Aufruf, in dem steht,
Korrektiv oder die Journalisten oder wie auch immer, müssen in die Schranken gewiesen werden.
In die Schranken weisen ist ein indirekter Aufruf zur Gewalt. Das ist nicht ein Witz.
Beatrix von Storch hat heute nochmal in einem Video meinen Namen genannt,
mich als linksradikalen Gewalttäter bezeichnet, weil ich immer einen Tortor
ins Gesicht geworfen habe, ein bisschen Sahne, tut mir leid,
das fand ich gerechtfertigt.
Stand ihr eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Gut, aber daraus macht die eben einen linksradikalen Gewalttäter und warum machen die das?
Weil die natürlich unsere Arbeit diffamieren wollen und ich möchte, dass wenn,
irgendwas passiert, irgendeinem Kollegen, einer Kollegin von mir oder mir selber,
dass im Vergleich zu Stefan Ernst, der Walter Lübcke umgebracht hat,
wo es irgendwie einen AfD-Bezug gab, der war glaube ich in der Partei oder gespendet,
aber die haben es an sich abträufeln lassen können.
Jetzt gibt es klare Signale aus der Spitze der AfD gegen Korrektiv. Das sind Aufrufe.
Die darf man nicht übersehen. Das ist ein sogenanntes Dogwhisting.
Dass die Blutspur, sollte etwas passieren, direkt bis in die Parteizentrale führt.
Ich möchte nicht, dass wenn etwas passiert, die AfD damit mit wegkommt.
Und das ist das eine und das andere ist, wo ich wirklich dankbar wäre,
ist unterstützt korrektiv in dem Sinne, dass ihr guckt, was könnt ihr für Online Angriffe finden.
Wir wissen schon von ein paar Angriffen, wir wissen von Versuchen,
so scheint es auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben aktuell Gebäudeschutz in mehreren Redaktionen. Staatliche Behörden
nehmen das sehr, sehr ernst.
Aber das ist eine Situation, die man nicht unterschätzen darf.
Wir haben eine Partei im Bundestag, die auf Journalistenjagd geht,
nachdem die kritisiert wurden.
Und genau, wir machen weiter. Wir lassen uns davon nicht beirren.
Wir haben Spaß an der Arbeit.
Wir wollen dem standhalten.
Aber tut uns einen Gefallen, unterstützt uns damit, hinweisen.
Alles, was ihr finden könnt. Wenn ihr irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken findet
in unserer vielleicht etwas löchrigen Architektur, wer weiß schon,
dann sagt uns das. dass die Stopfen, also genau, da seid ihr stark und da sind
wir dankbar für die Unterstützung.
Ja, wir haben diese Sache mit dem Dog Whistling.
Anderer Begriff, der glaube ich in dem Kontext ist, der stochastische Terrorismus.
Also man kennt dieses Muster, dass halt Menschen, die finden dann so Erwähnungen,
und dann haben die halt mal irgendwie von jemandem, der in der Nähe wohnt,
irgendwas an der Haustür gesprüht oder kriegen mal einen auf die Fresse,
oder landen irgendwie wie Rudi Dutschke mit einer Kugel im Kopf auf dem Kurfürstendamm.
Also das sind so Dinge, die dann so passieren.
Wir haben das veröffentlicht, wir haben eine Geschichte veröffentlicht von Mario
Müller, der genau das macht. Wir haben gesagt, guck mal, was er macht.
Und genau dasselbe im Prinzip passiert dann plötzlich mit dem Redakteur,
der das veröffentlicht hat. Also das ist sozusagen Wir.
Haben da jetzt CCC uns auch zu positioniert. Die AfD spielt hier ganz bewusst
und absichtlich mit dem Risiko, dass tägliche Angriffe folgen.
Beim von Korrektiv aufgedeckten Treffen brüstete sich ein Mitarbeiter eines
AfD-Bundestagsabgeordneten sogar mit Gewaltaktionen.
Und ich finde das auch, also ich finde das sehr gut, dass du das jetzt auch
nochmal angesprochen hast, Jean, weil das ist jetzt das, was da durchaus als
nennenswertes Risiko im Raum steht.
Und am Ende ist das dann ein bedauerlicher Einzeltäter, verwirrt,
ein bisschen zu viel Bild gelesen und so und dann schafft man es wieder,
sich davon loszureißen. reißen.
Nee, diesmal nicht. Dieses Gewicht müssen wir denen jetzt ans Bein tun.
Ich meine, ich fahre jetzt erstmal natürlich nach Malagaskar,
das ist ja klar. Ich weiß nicht.
Der ganze Soros-Kohle jetzt irgendwo hin.
Naja, so ist es.
Aber das ist,
beängstigend. Wir werden jetzt glaube ich nicht im Detail darüber reden oder
ich werde jetzt gar nicht danach fragen, welche welche Schutzmaßnahmen ihr habt, aber ich hoffe,
dass die ordentlich sind und kann jetzt glaube ich jede Mal auf sich wirken lassen,
was dir wohl blüht oder wie viele Irre das jetzt auch gesehen haben,
die sich durch alle wirklichen Aufrufe da inspiriert fühlen.
Insbesondere in einem Kontext, wo du auf bild.de davon nicht liest.
Zumindest nicht auf der Startseite.
Mittlerweile gibt es da schon einen Bericht, aber das ist halt auch...
Ja, es gab auch einen Bericht, dass die Organisatorin der Demo irgendwie eine Extremistin ist. Echt?
Auf Bild?
Ja, ich habe das heute Morgen hier auf Mastodon verteilt und da gab es dann
so ein bisschen Reaktionen, die mir einerseits Artikel gezeigt haben,
andererseits dann irgendwie,
ja, also irgendeine Form von Versuchen, diese Demos zu diffamieren, ne.
Aber ja, das ist jetzt eine sehr große Neuigkeit mit sehr großem Impact und
die wird jetzt von diesen AfD-Leuten in einen komplett anderen Kontext gerissen.
Linksradikale Gewalt und hast du alles nicht gesehen und Lügenpresse,
das kennen die ja alle schon. Und das ist auch etwas, was die...
Die können ja kommen, die können ja juristisch kommen. Wir sind im Rechtsstaat.
Ja, juristisch machen sie nix.
Genau, das ist doch kein Problem. Wenn das nicht stimmt, was wir berichtet haben,
dann kommt doch. Das brauchen sie ja nicht.
Die brauchen ja nicht den Rechtsstaat. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht ihr Ziel.
Den brauchen sie zum Abschieben.
Also die Gefahr ist da und vor dem Hintergrund muss man auch echt nochmal wirklich
den Ja, es ist einfach nur Mut sowas durchzuziehen,
zu veröffentlichen, unter seinem Namen und sich da hinzustellen.
Und dafür gebührt einfach mal absoluter Respekt und höchste Anerkennung für
die gesamte Kollektivredaktion, die das ja gemeinsam gemacht hat.
Du bist einer der Beitragenden, jetzt derjenige, der für uns in Berlin halt
am nächsten war, um ihn in die Sendung einzuladen und alle, die daran mitgewirkt haben,
höchster Respekt, weil die natürlich wissen, dass sie alle sich da eine große
Zielscheibe auf die Stirn gemalt haben.
Ja.
Hoffentlich nicht.
Naja.
Die ist jetzt erstmal da und das ist halt jetzt eine Frage des gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhaltes, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Menschen unantastbar sind.
Und dazu noch muss ich aber sagen, all die Menschen, die jeden Tag Rassismus
erleben, die machen das ohne, dass sie einen Artikel veröffentlicht haben,
sind die unter Gefahr. Also das dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Viele Menschen fragen nicht danach und trotzdem kriegen jeden Tag Anfeindungen.
So, Jean, jetzt kriegst du aber nochmal ein persönliches Dankeschön dafür, dass du hier warst. Ja.
Danke, danke, dass ich hier sein durfte.
Ja, wir haben es jetzt ausführlich bearbeitet, hoffe ich.
Lange Sendung, ne? Ja, es ist immer so lang bei dem Thema angemessen lang.
Das denke ich auch.
Schön, also vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Es war wirklich toll,
mal hier im Studio vorbeizukommen.
Ich mag ja eure Sendung sehr und freue mich auf die nächsten.
Jetzt weißt du, wie es sich anfühlt.
War uns eine Freude und Ehre, dich hier zu haben. Du nimmst mit deine Geschenke.
An der Stelle auch immer gerne Spenden an Korrektiv.
Spenden an Korrektiv.
Wir leben von Spenden. Wir leben nur von Spenden. Hauptsächlich zumindest die
Redaktion lebt nur von Spenden.
Genau, kommt gerne und unterstützt uns. Es gibt Hinweise, wenn ihr irgendwas
weiß. Irgendwelche Onkels, die Grundgesetz,
verachtende Dinge tun und planen. Wir freuen uns über jeden.
Wenn ihr im Security-Bereich arbeitet, dann könnt ihr mal ein paar Überstunden abarbeiten.
Genau.
Toll, vielen Dank.
So. Ich würde sagen, damit machen wir Schluss.
Was haben wir jetzt in den letzten Monaten, in den letzten Wochen?
geile Gäste und Themen hier gehabt. Jetzt müssen wir aber irgendwann auch mal
wieder über Netzpolitik reden.
Machen wir das nächste Mal. Okay, alles klar. Bis dann. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.